[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sunday sunday sunday
what's going on around how we doing
might check my check
and all that what's going on talk to you
let me know how the levels is
sunday easter sunday at least everybody
in there
aim down scope what's going on
bearing down okay i think i know what
you talking about
let me go yeah that was going to have a
lot to say
lost forever plays what's up no doubt
doovey what's going on
death mobile the homie what's going on
good to see you and of course the
legendary
gerald mack appreciate you but i saw the
video
you know i'm saying every given
motivation get a lot of motivation
to get up and do the show look a little
tired the lord's tired everybody's doing
a lot of stuff right now we got packs
coming up so we've been prepping for
that
you know work's been crazy for me
so you know
what's going on daniel mcgee from i
can't even say facebook
meta you're saying what's going on but
yeah there's been a lot going on so you
know we kind of we're kind of burning
the candle but we're gonna recharge
pax's i'm super hyped
you know what i mean oh man we got the
bestie in there dj orros my man sunday
sunday sunday sunday sunday i remember
them commercial
salute to the homie good to see him at
gcx that's gonna be fun akw what's up
phantom knife what's up tommy says
what's up see mac what's going on the
elden lord versus that little iron lords
okay okay let's see what's going on
black conflict x let's go
see i had to show up
back black
[Music]
bestie the besties in the building
getting it out now
um
lydia master what's up
happy easter happy easter everybody
so yeah i'm just going to talk y'all for
a little bit um the king will be
rolling through
gotta find attic i know he's up well we
just got to find him
no solve today no socks so i've told
y'all last week he's doing okay he's
just got a big move going on
so he will not be here we won't see him
i won't see him actually until um
packs we're gonna meet up there in
boston
[Music]
so we'll get up in there and then um
take care of business so no no no solve
today but send some love even though
king don't be liking me to say love song
anyway let me go see if i can find the
young wolf see what's going on with him
get king up in here and uh we're gonna
have to have a good show like i said
salute to y'all for pulling up on easter
and everybody usually spend time with
their families and stuff like that so
we'll expect like a crazy show but it's
just cool to see everybody pull up
anyway to hear what the lords are
talking about
so we're gonna get to it i'm gonna talk
to y'all
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and headless be swearing
that real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah i be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting
oh
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we were
messaging people on aim
[Music]
very spoiled for them to be your dog's
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on aim
check my
[Music]
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my
vocals on twitter but i'm anti-social
love my city but i'm still by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta missed up and turned me
to an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you were messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny word to carnita who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this
[Music]
all right uh we were late but uh i need
to know mike check if the realm can hear
us and
make sure they can hear y'all that's the
main thing right now is we we having all
type of issues to date so mike check
talk to the people right quick cause i'm
not even getting a volume level
let me know if y'all can hear attic king
let me know
can you hear this is gonna be the very
you can hear
them you could say hit cog though but
what about then what about
what about the lords see just you hold
on
talk see can't hear anybody but
see they talking they say king is mute
that's the thing all right give me a sec
that's what i was worried about
oh
spaghettio hold on a second
remember that
all right let's switch put into the foot
chef boyardee now i see levels see your
levels we we
all right what about that we outside
king's purple coats talking
dude can y'all hear me though that's
what i'm saying i hear them
now yeah
all right gene says good
akw said he got king all right okay
all right
yeah yeah
yo we paid the bill in time for the show
all right
man we we sit there and we was like yo
yeah colleges you pay the the stream
lives bill he's like oh gosh
it was a rough buff i was in the club
you don't see i buy the blue that
i don't know i buy the blue
powder
invested into a deal he couldn't resist
listen man that best gg i just blew all
the money right now man we were
so welcome and happy easter till the
iron lords [ __ ] yes
llc and also live on
lordsofgaming.net we're not going to be
professional today that type of thing um
and today
we've got
hadeo kojima and playstation studio
rumors
halo infinite battle royale rumors
gaming subscription guidelines
and european sales data to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the four well we missing one
horseman
shout out to soft you say getting his
move on brother we will see you at um
pax which we will be absolutely salute
to him you know what i mean but we still
got three other horsemen and a special
guest that came in this cape
so shout out to my co-host with the
colbos my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my bad lord addict how we doing
doing pretty good man uh you know what i
actually got back into
minecraft i only played minecraft in
years like years
all right and i didn't realize how they
say that game has changed over the years
it's saying
right now but like i'm eventually going
to have to switch back yeah because i
got the busted [ __ ] everything's busted
today
griggity sounds low added i mean uh dirt
make sure your windows levels is a
little higher
yeah
yeah shout out shout out the game
perspective you already know
okay cool cool cool they say they all
sound fine but you're just a little fine
you're better better better there we go
there we go okay cool cool let's go so
anyway what was going on with you man
yeah so i've been jumping back into some
minecraft man okay okay how you like it
it's it's it's they changed that game
drastically like it's not the same game
anymore like they have these realm
things now where like people can put
mods now i know people have
people don't for some reason the mod
community don't like when people
try to profit off their mods i don't
know what that's about like they prefer
everything to be free and it's just like
look if these people put this kind of
time into making these mods you know
they should be compensated for it
like what's funny is is the same people
want all support to death but they don't
want to support the people making the
mall
[Laughter]
it makes no sense to me but it's it's
been a fun time you know me and my
friend we bought a um a realm
okay where it's like it's like open 24
7.
so just come in we keep the light on
keep the light up for you
so i'm just surprised like what got you
back into that though on just
zachary's been trying to get me to play
for years and i was just like you know
what well
he looks like i meant that else to play
ain't nothing else out right now
it was the ray tracing yeah i was like
the ray tracy rumors got you yeah oh no
you whenever i ever cared about anything
like that
this is the episode it's just something
else to like
i'm not gonna say that there's
absolutely nothing to play right now but
like it's stuff that interests me it's
it's far between i don't know so it's
just like you know i went ahead and
[Music]
was like i might as well just go ahead
and
play what i could play you know the
realm is they harass you what happened
to addict's camera let's see his build
[Laughter]
here's what happened like
i guess the welding on my my chair was
generic when it was made so it like
snapped in half like the bottom part
that connects my chair to like the
little roll spin thing
with the wheels yeah it really will and
like
i have to sit in like a kitchen chair
right now and the reason i don't have my
camera on is because
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's you got five minutes with those
cheeks
no cushion no back support
no circulation
right now it's wrong
i feel your food you know don't know
that's been it sir
yeah that's literally all i've been
playing is minecraft that's the only
thing holding back the flatulence he
better hold on
yeah whatever it is it was good overall
purple chairs yeah
and of course when we don't get my
brother's son the technical gaming lord
set up some love he is moving he's okay
because you know just for the records
this week
we will see our brother impacts east
along runaway dragon tv what's going on
over if i see
what's up in the building you already
know but homie yo yeah of course of
course and of course we still got the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues demands nothing less than that
premium experience and is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved and a successful
live show combat talk
how we doing sir
first of all i want to thank everybody
one the the 1k views that i did get
from the debut show
it's fantastic and the dudes that rock
with me throughout the whole show
my peoples pulled up sent in super chats
uh because they thought i could only see
color no uh
[Music]
he said i'm sorry your man got beat down
last night king who got
i don't know i guess he tried to imply i
guess he want to put that he want to add
who god's to me god bless if you think
ooh guys on my side whatever you know
last night was a great night for boxing
um errol spence went in there and see
this is what i tell you man don't be
counting your chickens before they hatch
and don't be saying some stuff that you
can't back up
they told
spence that his eye won't stand up for
the fight because remember he had the
eye injury yes
why did they stop oogaz why did they
stop the fight cause your eye literally
was folded up into the side of your head
he
i my my wife and i
have realized this thing about spence
what's up all that stuff y'all talk
all that father y'all give this dude
energy he is probably the most malicious
petty dude
[Laughter]
on god in them
he's gonna get a hold of crawford
is he
and i'm gonna tell you what he got first
of all crawfish is light in the butt he
a little dude okay all right and
everybody's gonna say though
listen he looked nice fighting joe
schmoe
sean porter and then they job sean put a
job there
he retired to the next day uh crawford
on my show you beat my butt the night
before i'm not on your show tomorrow i
don't know
he job that night i don't care he made
money he knew he was going out he job he
put the dude over the top go ahead go
inside wow
when y'all when uh and i know you're
gonna say oh but spins he got rock
yesterday yeah my piece came out he took
his eyes off the prize and got hit
upside his head that's exactly what was
supposed to happen his legs were
supposed to get buckled and he was
supposed to get folded up into the
corner but what he did after that no he
decided to lunchbox his whole head up
and ship it out listen
all you crawfit fans i tell you he's a
savant but he's a light in the butt
savant okay he's trying to pick his
little spots
he could have been fort spence and i
told y'all watching the stream mm-hmm
this dude
picked the wrong dog to get
you survived a car crash you survived
death like you've seen that bro i've
seen that ferrari flip he shouldn't be
alive everyone should not be alive after
that car crash he shouldn't be fighting
okay
you shouldn't be fighting yeah you
should be you shouldn't be fighting
world world champions
all right so enough about that go watch
the combat talk thank you guys for
hanging out it was so dope combat talk
could be back again after pax um and kos
is on its way that's something totally
that's a live show too
um
elden ring let's go
oh man i made it to this this fire giant
first of all he's not as hard as kids
move and was making it out to be
[Laughter]
i mean
they did four hours fighting this dude
but i made it to the first time
i mean the fire giant and
you know god you fight him he's mad big
he's bigger than the whole screen
you got to beat his ankles in
until his legs break
and then his legs
gotta rough his ankle up yeah then he
goes into the second phase and so he
can't run around he start rolling around
on the floor
you do enough damage to his ankle he
snaps his ankles they just crack up
okay and then he's on the floor
these dudes they have jokes they have
it's fun i love the game i love if i
kill somebody by mistake i miss that
quest so i got to do a replay um well
actually there's actually a
a mechanic in the game where you'll go
to like this this cathedral and it says
pray for your mistakes and it brings
back anyone that have quest back to life
oh you talk about the church of vows
yeah okay yeah i got a vow and they said
i didn't need any all right cool that's
what's up that's what but um yeah i was
playing that in guardians of the galaxy
game pass has been acting up i've been
dropping too much stuff right now stuff
that i do want to play but elder ring
has my soul so yeah elder rick got you
man that's what's up though you already
know and of course we got
coming in with the cape right now one of
them you got one of my favorite intros
when that woo ain't hit
right here
i'll be like that's that's my generation
right there you know i love about it i
don't give my be monetized yeah i was
about heating
did not see this
yeah hey so like i just tried it the
first time i said okay they missed this
one i kept on doing it
demonetization i love it the legendary
lord dirk griggity of the wbg
xbox podcast what's going on sir
what is up man yo i can't listen man
listen i'll be waiting to get on this
show i've been on here twice within a
couple of months
listen man you're doing things right
doing things right man
thank you for pulling out for us man
again coming through you know what i'm
saying appreciate that let's get a
couple of super chats addicts you got
him on deck or you want me to grab a
couple of them
uh i can get as many as like all right i
got from the beginning so
and then you could just catch me up oh
daddy's gonna be you already got him
uh no no okay
i got from the beginning so yeah so this
is gonna be a little messy because we
don't got solved today so excuse us um
all right so we got my man uh looks like
uh skywalker the jedi oh that was for me
yesterday though you were talking about
the um
the fight the normal app okay evan p
twenty on super chat my favorite iron
lord to watch okay nobody talk about the
fight you know that my man looks like
into the mind of phil spencer what's
good king at work watching his stream so
that was last night and then we got um
happy east okay sith lord happy easter
my lords i hope you're all having a
great day salute you already know and we
got ko3 black truth five dollar super
chat happy easter to my favorite ogs and
the young wolf no doubt hard fine with
the two dollar super chat being very
messy y'all even got attic or cp time
wow
that's crazy dt y'all know it's cpvs for
those that know dt taylor finalism great
watch party last night king we got paid
last night oh that's what's up
big cloud gaming shout out two dollar
super chat everybody's sending a prayer
for addicts back
yeah that [ __ ] i see that chair shout
out to italian clowns 10 out of super
chat or hail the king shout out to
clowns you already know hollywood rules
throughout super chat excellent job king
on fight talk talk hashtag dead cheeks
so funny um all right we got you then we
got let's see let's see we got ko three
against the certain age they started
coming out with mandatory cushions for
those yes
those are the back breakers shout out
five hours in the chat dirt what's good
i've been listening to you tts that last
few weeks
love the show real talk you hashtag pos
okay you got your gang members in here
you got your shooters in here
[Laughter]
the ray tracing twins are here oh
king of dirt
[Laughter]
that's why i want a
okay okay lucious augustus 5 000. salute
to the iop and dirt no other podcast
compares to your professionalism after
what i saw this weekend involving jaffa
yeah shout out to jeff he's going
through it right now he's going through
it right now the
twitter comment oh the comment boy is
not happening we didn't see it
yeah it's very serious right now do not
mention the word dlc that's what i'm
going to say
don't mention yo the streets is talking
it's real serious right now but of
course we got the gaming that jam sound
the [ __ ] don't be low incognito
spreading that rumors in the opera iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to
finally duke shout out to maddie plays
had a banging last stand media joint
with defining duke is up right now on
youtube you know we're talking about the
certain infinity giant we started
talking about um just usual defining
duke banter can you love it because we
had somebody asked us like embarrassing
moments in gaming and i said i brought
up all the things we used to do to
people with people that broke their bike
and people that had to carry other
people down the street when they lost in
the game
they had the walking dead yeah the
hazing they're taking the punt [ __ ]
walk they got all the stories so if you
want funny stories definitely check out
do it for that dirt
the craziest thing man i gotta say that
i gotta say the butt naked
so we playing nba live right it was live
right i think so was it 2k it might have
been live
okay no i think it was 2k i think it was
2k oh it could have been live the kyrie
irving whatever one it didn't matter
i'll take scottie pippen i don't care
what you're going to do or iverson if i
take iverson it's a wrap yeah i mean
right right so
i'm playing my cousin
and
i'm talking hella dude crap right i
don't i don't play this game but he do
this is his joint this is butter
so you know how when somebody says
something so outrageous you're supposed
to back down mm-hmm
he said
if you lose you gotta walk down
and that goes for you too if you lose
you gotta walk on the street naked now
he he expected me to back down the
counter because i knew this wasn't my
game right yo dirk
he played around the
toy with me all the way to the fourth
quarter yeah and he thought he can turn
it on in the fourth quarter
[Music]
i am not gonna lie it was my greatest
comeback
[Music]
uh i was down
two points
i was down two points
from the corner
inbound i don't know if it was scotty or
i don't know if it was iverson
buzzer sounds
like a second shot money
cash
money
[Laughter]
go on bunk bananas and then like you
gotta get outside you gotta shut up
cheeks
[Laughter]
he took his pants down he walked down
the block
i'm telling you right now
story
what's up
there's a vision a version of that story
where your man's gets puts on the sex
offender listen
if a black dude walking down the street
in the bronx and he butt naked they just
gonna think you're on drugs
oh he's he's smoking he's moving
powder
anyway yo shout out to 108 dragon tv
pulling up of the dragons dead what's
going on bro
a long night so i'm gonna be taking some
water breaks appreciate you now we're
gonna need y'all want to wait away
you're gonna be in the building packs
east with the lords you know what i'm
saying so get it out of your system now
get out your sister what's been going on
with you
[Laughter]
thanks for having me always a pleasure
always
that's what it's the code for the spaces
gangs
you got to do it you know 30 days of
coach is still popping this is that
marmot so if y'all want to go google the
price go google that oh my god every
time y'all bigger scenes we're wearing
fancy coats let's get it
yo addie give me a sound i think we
missed donald taco
taco's um
member
let me go back yeah so check check my
wife said when they make a toy of me
they're gonna make it with multiple
coats so you can switch out my coat
[Laughter]
he said it was a member chat because
yeah i can't yo just re-put it in the
chat and tag one of us yeah donald trump
you guys gonna have to be very patient
with us because not all like i'm not at
my pc
i saw that [ __ ]
yeah so if if you guys if we miss
something you're just gonna have to
re-put it in the chat so we can read it
don't just tag one of us in it and don't
expect them to get up and sprint across
the room because his legs is jelly
all right no doubt let's see if we got
shout out to hollywood world followers
which i have easter to my iop bros ilp
is the pregame to my brooklyn nets
listen to fight talk on my birthday last
night dope weekend prank praying for
addict's cheeks with that chair no doubt
[ __ ] j five
yeah gj files which swami king please
tell these fools that the activision
deal is going through and playstation is
not going to buy kojima production long
live kojima xbox cloud exclusive you got
this let them have some hope please
don't shut the door down on their head
they ain't got no games right now just
let them live
wow
playing with the 5 island super chat
happy easter sending my lp brothers hope
you all have a great show and remember
kojima is a white game developer oh
slander what are we doing
oh man we all over the place today they
saying we missed forte i ain't even
seeing them joints what's going on
adam you gotta help me out bro i'm i see
records yeah
we gotta get forte oh that's crazy let
me refresh that we got to get forte that
that that's a violation we don't get
that you know what i'm saying we miss
donald taco
pulling up the old joint right quick the
reason that i i get frustrated with
these member chat things because they're
nowhere they're not real member chats
don't even know if you don't
yeah i don't see it fourteen i'm looking
[Laughter]
all right so cool we all caught up there
did you find anything to add just before
i keep no i i've i looked again like
yeah it's not there
the only thing that
that shows up on our end is super chats
like
the only way we could see the members if
it's red before it leaves the chat so if
you did a member chat just tag us
and put members chat and then tag one of
us in that chat and we'll read it okay
[Laughter]
you're ridiculous no doubt so check that
out we got also we got the definitely
ultimate patreon episode check that out
we had my man ty guy travis ty
richardson of watch mojo talk about
freelancing just how to get in the game
the you know the stuff for the ign that
was going on shout out to the last word
thai guy again and ibontas got a great
shirt by my man save the blade came on
really cool dude helps a lot of people
do raids and all that stuff for me as
far as gaming it's been mlb the show
that's the still getting my little demo
for the home team shoot the whole team
you know what i'm saying so i've been
rocking that all right let's get into
this poll right quick last week's poll
results are in the people have spoken
with the latest gdc tech demo of ue5
which xbox game studio project has you
most excited in terms of graphical
fidelity the winner in a very
competitive 45 of the vote was hell
blade 2
coming in at a razor close second
percent well second place at 40 percent
of the vote was the messy lords i don't
care you already know whatever coalition
is doing they are the lords of unreal
agent five so bend the knee group in
third place only twelve percent out of
worlds two ruben on unreal engine five
and in last place sadly with only two
percent of the vote was read for they
they did not they was impressed
i got to see more on red paul before i
get excited for red fall like okay
nothing what i saw like and i've never
really particularly liked those type of
games i just got to see more in terms of
what that gameplay looking like there's
the same guy that's half arcane there's
over uh what was that uh what the
guardians of the game what's that game
starlight or whatever the hell it is
star field yeah
yourself confused with me man
write what you did said and tag me he
said game stop not paying me anymore to
check man i don't know if the check
cleared on that super checkers
i got i got some um game stop points
though they just hit stupid he sent me
game style points no doubt thx one one
three eight final super chat god award
dlc ragnarok full price from sony
studios ps5 for the payers you are messy
sir this is true this is true
i think we all knew it was going to be
full price if anyone didn't think that
game wasn't going to be full price then
you know i i i got some land that i
don't own that i could sell you so
anyway
so we're gonna jump right into the first
topic um hideo kojima in the news man in
the news a lot a lot going on so shout
out to my boy nicholas downey of
lordsgaming.net put up an article about
uh whether kojima and playstation
studios are cooking so basically let's
the timeline starts off there was a
pretty much a simple like first party
studios banner by playstation i guess
their social teams had
shared it and in there um they found the
main character from that stranding um
sam as a focal character in the game
along with the other you know
traditional ips from sony which led to a
lot of speculation that it represented
first party releases from uh playstation
so the question became does that mean
that you know the acquisition went down
so um
twitter actually before kojima corrected
he did retweet he did retweet the image
that banner the fame damage image of
playstation studios and that logo but
then after that i believe from his
american account he treated it from the
japanese account from his american
account he says i'm sorry for the
misunderstanding but kojima productions
has been been and why you're laughing
and we'll continue from your american
account from your japanese account
without your american account uh there's
some something fishy with that going on
oh for my japanese audience
nah stand behind the wall
don't get too close to me that's what
we're doing so he said yeah i'm sorry
for the misunderstanding but kajima
productions has been and will continue
to be an independent studio twitter's on
fire
twitter is on fire with this and we
gonna set this off dirk griggity what do
you think about what's going on here
with kajima play are they who's who's
playing games what's happening i think
kojima is trolling he's enjoying himself
he has the playstation fans just
up not like what what what
listen
listen now
i'm not on my channel
i appreciate it i'm sorry
lord lord cognito brother it was
hilarious
it was hilarious
i've seen many tweets i'm not gonna say
any names
take that you box oh
kojima sounds just like jada
so shima is signing
with playstation he's being acquired by
playstation i saw people call out jeff
grubb uh jeff gordon what are you
talking about uh it was hilarious but i
will say this let's go kojima's having a
little fun okay right kojima is having a
little fun we don't know what's really
going on true me personally i uh trust
jeff grub and he said that
kojima is working on the xbox game right
because that was what was in question
people were like hey does that mean that
the rumored xbox deal you know might be
off because of this acquisition so to
speak
yeah yeah so and like i trust jeff well
because his track record is pretty good
yes um so you know i just thought it was
funny
um this whole situation and and i saw
people say yo sony did that with detroit
become human they put a character from
detroit because become human on on uh
you know
the wallpaper or whatever you want to
call it before sony owns the ip okay
that's it they own ip
and um i think kojima was wrong for
trolling playstation
[Laughter]
108 dragons tv lola mythius man what do
you think about this whole hadeo kojima
situation no no no call me the name that
dirk changed my nickname to and got
people saying it now i don't even know
what they changing to dirt
is what are you guys
[Laughter]
status
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
god yo listen let me tell you what's up
man this dude
is like the chick on the corner he's for
rent you go and purchase a little bit
he's going back to a man that's that's
what it is man
that game
was was financed by sony so if they
added that
to their billboard or they or their
situation that's because they pay for it
okay you understand that's like that's
like microsoft advertising uh sunset
overdrive
same thing but you know what happens
with people
they need cannon fodder they see this
type of stuff
they're making podcasts they're just
running crazy with no with no no
background checks no no no nothing to
fall back on that's all it was
i mean they're supposed to advertise
they stuff
it's an exclusive it's not coming to
xbox it's only going to pc and they're
only hp they're supposed to do it okay
so now that they advertise something
that they pay for oh my god they
purchased them nobody said okay you know
nothing wrong with it fair enough i do
want to uh follow back just for fairness
for both dirt and 108 with very strong
opinions here um
now we have seen in the past
them kind of let the cat the bag out
early but uh
blue point and the banner went up
right and then oh no no no and then blue
marks said kind of the same thing they
were almost there
we're not acquired and then the next
thing you know
i mean but you know sir you know when
you
we all businessmen here most of us right
we all know how things are you know you
can't let the cat out of bag too early
true and the deal is in the works but
once it becomes official it would be sad
so it could be a situation like that but
i just think you just was advertising a
game they paid for i'm fair enough fair
enough fair enough you know what's that
lord addict man you got some issues with
uh accounts japanese accounts and how
tall kojima's handling his twitter
look man i'm gonna be road with you i'm
gonna be 100 with you caught it let's go
hey they could buy kojima i wouldn't
lose a night of sleep
i his games never appealed to me uh they
never will appeal to me
uh i feel like i have to do some really
hardcore drugs to appeal oh my oh
not even metal gear no you you got to
give a metal gear once they said
[Laughter]
know i'm not even kajima guy like that
now here's the thing remember the what
is it metal gear solid 2.
it was the demo i believe for ps2
ridiculous was at the time
the one that you're on that ship
and you will see that that was graphical
fidelity cinematics at its finest and
that was when you could put the bodies
you could put the bodies inside the the
little truck
it was amazing it was you know the only
thing i heard in that whole sentence
game oh god
ps2
oh
you got to say back in the day
oh
wow
that's like that's how you're talking
about that that that that nice one man
it's like you know remember that chick
back in the day she was like 20.
she now she's like 60 oh
oh
she she passed up prime
i agree with that one i agree with
adding
she ain't got it no more anything hey i
agree with how to go now because this
last two games i wasn't feeling them at
all
at all
i'm sorry um until i'm proven otherwise
until proven otherwise i'm on that
standpoint where it's like maybe konami
kept this man like tethered to reality
so his games actually came out good oh
wow i feel like i feel like kojima
unleashed
is not the kojima that we need
you like a controlled kajima you like
you like chicks
i really feel like yeah dude he needs
more checks and balances than the
government does like
it's it's crazy if you think like if you
look at the game like that's training
and you really look at that stranding
why did that anyone think that game was
going to hit
i agree with you like we we years into
marketing and no one can tell you what
that game's about a lot of people and
then when we and then when we asked
kojima he don't even know what it's
really yeah
[Laughter]
you don't even get the iop cap you get
the ichi face cap that's cash
don't do that i'm not saying that the
man can't make good games all i've said
is like you got to start proving that
you even worthy being bought like that's
why i like
when people talking when people talking
about oh you know him yeah playing
another example platinum like people
talking about oh you know
people talking about
about you know companies being bought
this and that it's just like look like
if if you sat there and you thought oh
what can playstation buy to combat
kojima i mean to combat xbox
i'm calvin in the in the room see yo
kojima looking pretty good right now
that's what you feel lord king
where you at with all this news
playstation studios lurking you feel
this oh man
it was crazy about it how y'all gonna
cap for a chick that was only dating you
like she was only hanging out with you
she was only sliding your house she was
only putting games on your table but you
got here yo she exclusive now shut up
she could have been exclusive this whole
time nobody cared
nobody kid you know what really makes
sense like what makes sense it only
matters if kojima signed with xbox
that only matters if she's not if he
signs with playstation
this is why i'm saying it
because they know automatically
xbox has japanese cachet right
he signs
with the team that he's been playing for
for forever
that doesn't move the needle in no way
i will say why should we give him a back
like sorry go ahead sorry i will say one
thing
uh i don't agree like look if he wants
to come if he came on his xbox as like a
studio i would be a little disappointed
but if he came on as like an ambassador
that he's there to strengthen the
relationships between microsoft then i
would be a little bit more on that and
look like just because i don't like
kojima games there's a lot of people who
do you know they yeah i'd question you a
question
wrong with that but they're living in
the past
this ain't 92.
but i mean i mean we wouldn't say
death stranding soldier oh come crazy i
don't know that's fine better buck on
the death strand
he he picked the wrong team the
infrastructure wasn't right the game
wasn't exactly what it's supposed to be
so he he made his bed over there he
grabbed the bag with the dudes that he
was messing with and why because there
was a trusted brand there was somebody
he was messing with already again
whatever he does over there is not going
to move the needle at all because he's
already been over there so why buy the
cow when the milk is free all right so
let's don't make no shout out to connor
you know i'm jumping ahead on superchat
he's about to make the point that i was
about to say he said what about kojima
studios deal could be like bungie's deal
because everybody said the same thing
with sony acquired the street they was
like yeah they straight they were like
why because bungie came out specifically
said no we're still independent we still
put our games here and playstation still
bought them
so then what does that mean what does
that say to my whole paradigm that sony
is looking for end game out because if
if that's the matter why what what
this is what i'm saying break it down if
this becomes the trend
we purchase you but you can make games
everywhere
um yeah what's up well right what what
if it's what if i take the cut okay
i was gonna say what if
when they got bungee right
they're not looking okay bungee like yo
we don't want to be on we want to do
what we want to do so but now
they can get it cut whereas when they're
making their own money you don't see
nothing right
but now they get a higher percentage
they get the 700 instead of the 30 right
right that's all they did you invested
yeah but bungie makes see but to me
bungie makes more sense than kojima
productions because we know
playstation wants to be involved with
the games as a service yeah he's one of
the best at it you're right and they
need the expertise so to me
buying kojima productions and letting
them remain multi-black makes absolutely
no sense because he makes single player
games and i
i don't know
yeah yeah i don't know that would be
you know the case
king has a great point right if why why
why why about a cow when the milk is
free but check this out they bought they
bought house mark nobody zombie i
thought so insomniac also nobody care
cause y'all been in that bed already so
you bought something you already had so
it doesn't matter but what what about
this though i hear where y'all going
you're not wrong for the mentality that
you're saying as far as the why but my
question is we know
god dirt went away like
oh there's a good chance
i'm just saying we know that it's
acquisition seat like this is cuffing
season right now yeah so if you don't if
you don't lock something down for the
winner
your joint could be over there on xbox
or
or 10 cent
you know what i'm saying
embrace it there's a lot of people
that's outside i mean amazon's still
supposedly still in the game we got to
see what's going on with luna and all
that but
what
by the way don't do that don't do that
don't don't
don't you do that
oh man don't
nobody want to rent games that they
already own
i'm about to be lord luda for a second
new world old world man
look bill ring is here new world dead
let's go all right now i found out fair
enough but i'm just i was just curious
about that you know look i'll jump in i
thought this was wow like i i i was very
surprised
when i saw the banner
but the cabin though the captain needs
to stop why did stop what's that they
need to stop though stop jumping out the
windows guys save your legs
stop capping for companies making money
when they got they got 10 years of back
child support oh no no listen no i don't
i don't i don't know
what you're doing moving activism
bro
that's when we cap when when microsoft
by bethesda that's when we cap
we don't real i well i'm not capping off
no rumors but these dudes is capping
awful rumors yeah you know shout out to
house mark and that other rowdy
rebels died what are we doing did they
sign bobby what was that what was that
last acquisition
the last game that they made that was
like what 18 12 years ago that's when
bobby was hot
they were doing this money dance when he
was making a game
you just and then he purchased them so
we we looking just just just cap for the
stuff that you got man the stuff that
you're getting right now you're getting
bits and crumbs and
and this is not nothing to cap about
we buy bungee but she restrict listen
if this is true
right and kojima says
we are still independent we out here
we outside
that's an l
had to get in front of that statement
and say look we want it to be everywhere
we we we desire
so you hold it up okay you still hold it
onto your knees okay desire that's what
you're doing but also phil desires to
have game pass everywhere so if you
don't have it on your deck you
don't have dead cheeks i'm done i am
done with you wow look i feel which i'll
say it is an interesting situation i
have to
pay attention again the blue point thing
is the normally i'm 100 with y'all yeah
the only thing that makes me question no
no no no they're on their own thing i
think they he is being oh you don't care
like i just don't care if he's bald no i
don't know where we are
i'm right i'm right with him it don't
move the needle
it doesn't
you you you actually signed a contract
in a house in an apartment that you were
staying in anyway
if they were to buy something like
square enix then we'd have a different
conversation
a little with my feelings
am i really in my feelings when i'm not
getting those games on xbox anyway so
never mind i wouldn't care if they
bought them either and you got to ask
yourself what has he done lately
he made throat baby and throat
baby you know it's funny
yeah so it offered me like a hundred
dollars to stream uh death stranded a
couple months ago i was like no
the game just doesn't appeal to me not
for you i will say this you know i i was
curious too to see if the rumors were
true how does that affect the um the
rumored xbox exclusive that he's working
on we're supposed to have a letter of
intent well he got to finish it off and
get that through if you don't finish
that game i'm gonna tell you something
right now
you don't
i said kashima if they don't finish that
game
i'm gonna tell you right now
you're jeopardizing every playstation
fans warzone right
okay
a real game that they played not them
games that you make that only 35 percent
of the crowd look at these dudes over
here want that war zone and they want
that call of duty if you mess up and
don't give us the game that we paid for
you guys out there ain't going to get
what you want
i got it
puts those games where it's supposed to
be i got it listen shout out to jeff
grubb um with his reporting he said just
recently i was this the rumors and all
this commotion started with the gm
playstation he did say that the um the
deal as far as you know as far as two
weeks even as we said that's two weeks
ago that deal is still on as far as the
letter of interest oh i thought y'all
was talking about kashima they're living
the projects over on three yeah
anyway that's all i got let's see how
this thing plays out get a couple super
chats don't talk about it still stand
strong that i don't want that game
either
this is a genic gamer right now yeah he
just made a little bit rough today
i like when this camera's over
shout out to duck
taco who put he attacked me on the
member chat he said just got out of
easter service i thought i was gonna
miss some but y'all start late must have
been god's play happy easter y'all have
no doubt
[Music]
god slow the podcast down
[ __ ] j when that fight outside chat
when that light hits the sky all i see
is darkness all right
come on man
oh
no
oh that's [ __ ] jacob yeah i see what
you're doing stop that yeah how dare you
sir
apollo cooper dude
the moment xbox and now xbox announces
kojima we go to tts
yeah dirt
get your ghouls get your goals
i just realized i'm watching live shot
the gaming must be outside the weights
bro health is wealthy already make sure
you get that advanced gg we got that
power 10 percent off what i'm saying get
back
we got that for you get that sour you
know what i'm saying
cold iron lord want to check out anyway
oh moving on
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh your man says one of
your guys again seven eight six how are
you pronouncing this is sean is your
sean o'shea off guys
sean
sean my man five dollar five pound super
chat tts and wbj family in the house
let's talk that shh
shout out to my bro derp lemonis
crew everybody in the chat is tts tom
you already know salute
the gold the goons is out here
[Laughter]
spreading the good word of hack kojima
okay wow there's a lot of kojima
disrespecting it
it's not disrespectful just being honest
like
like no one played death stranding he
said yo this is it not no one did like
he
because you know you know playstation
should be like no backsies like
there ain't no refunds oh so they fought
they flushed it like that you gonna eat
that part there's no way possible they
can like it off of its own girl here
like the hardcore fans that's kojima
it's like a coat like once you go in
there you ain't leaving
i'm a hardcore fan and this game is
trash oh
that is clearly the pandas man not a fan
of it car now there's two dollars in the
chat kajima studios could be like the
bungee deal got you spectable 2000
kojima would never sell kojima
productions he's got pride oh man cut
that out
i've seen a lot of people talking about
pride and they walked out with none when
that
i heard cog wanted a special call out
like king so here we go and for the
first time ever hey cog hey my bestie
and as always hey kid
[Laughter]
italian clowns member fifteen months
salute brother all four guys and
quarters and all that um every sunday
just know the king is always right hail
the king bend those knees you already
know these is on deck and jonas the dad
all right we got the dazzle don't lose
the dad oh that's your people okay two
dollars
dirt i'm in the a.m iop afternoon happy
easter all right bonus what's up homie
hey god may you miss another member chat
for mike askew junior thank you brother
thank you
i can read the phrase yes please please
like you said what up realm yeah my son
is 17. he will be 23 by the time
kojima's games come out xbox is good
they're disrespectful and i appreciate
your help on it this is
you started that yeah
you know what i'm saying and we're gonna
get into this next one um halo infinite
attic i don't know if you want me to set
you up or you got it
yeah so look man there's a lot of
reports a lot of rumors going on um last
shout out to game rant who also have
read the story but did not give
the proper credit to lord chase corden
and the xbox two which it was probably
sourced from because it's definitely one
of the first absolutely i heard it so
the report went out um saying a new
massive battle royale game was in
development for halo infinite the size
is supposed to be comparable to scope to
warzone develop a certain affinity
brought in to support it with content
long term so then more information start
to come out now again this part is
definitely rumors i can't consider the
second part but a lot of data mine leaks
allegedly you know and the leaks were
shared by infinite
leaks on twitter which is known for data
mining halo infinite so it basically
could be split into topics regarding the
battle royale mode so they seem like
there looks to be um in this battle game
mode four choices there was tatanka
that's the code name duo's mode quads of
four that is default bots i guess battle
royale that is um another default mode
and they said ugc default ug tatanka
default ugc note that ugc is a flag used
in halo infinite to refer to game modes
so definitely it implies that there's a
four player version of this total game
mode which is a staple battle royale
game mode so attic the floor is yours
about these rumors and halo infinite man
what you think
i think that you know
here okay look there's a couple things
that you know we could go over there's a
couple discussions that we can go over i
know there's a lot of people who think
that
halo doesn't need a battle royale and to
a point i agree i do don't think halo
needs it but i do think that if halo
wants to compete in this
in this shooting market it's going to
need one
because at the end of the day like
arena's good for a lot of people but
the majority of that market that's on
fortnight that's on apex legends
they're they
they're in a
age group that ain't gonna be playing
arena
[Music]
facts it's like if you want them
you're going to have to get the battle
royale modes because
that is that's what is
popular that is what's streamable keep
in mind that a lot of success with these
games comes off who's streaming it how
it's being streamed and at the end of
the day do they need it no but i do
think that there needs to be a
conversation that's like is it unhealthy
for the game to have it and i don't i
don't i never thought it was like look
like you could have both
and especially with like certain
affinity coming in and they remember to
be working on this as long as they do a
good job supporting this and do a good
job keeping this game up to date why
does it matter you can actually bounce
back and forth you can have certain
cosmetics that you have to play the
arena mode to get it in battle royale
certain cosmetics you have to play
battle royale to get in the arena mode
you can bring the master chief
collection in
so it's just like
why not why only attack an army from one
direction when you can attack an army
from both
no thanks
man
let's get dirty then third man what do
you think about this uh roommate mode
it's looking not rude but it's looking
like this thing is committed it's
happening so what's your feelings on
this it's supposed to be this year isn't
it yeah yeah that's what he said
potentially i think maybe we'll see okay
i think it's a good thing because like
alex said it's a very popular mode
um it's huge on on twitch and things
like that and halo is a game that's been
around obviously since the early 2000s
one of the the best
like most popular first-person shooters
but it's okay to evolve right it's okay
to evolve with today's times and
and like addict said the the age group
that loves these br games no that's a
group that you want to grab you know
because they're playing these games
they're streaming these games
they're they're they're
like having them into your game will
benefit xbox right it definitely will no
doubt about it so i think it's a mode
that they should should have it's just
another mode
so what about what about the purest dirt
we don't want none of that in our halo
well like i said it's an option it's the
mold they're still going to have the
arena
you know
listen you know how to play the vr
you tell the peers that's not what you
tell them when they say yo i want this
to feel like halo we got a game for you
you wanted to feel like that old halo we
got a game that's called the master
chief collection there you go that's
over there and they're going to say
attic that match the chief collection
that's why it's doing better than if
they gonna say they're gonna stay gonna
pull out the steam numbers on you and
they're gonna say why don't they fix the
game first before they talk about adding
other modes how about they add a map
see here's the thing i don't think
you're right
there's technical issues that's in halo
infinite
but i think ever since they fixed the
big team battle the majority of the
issue is the content yeah and
they brought another studio to make the
halo infinite uh battle royale right so
it shouldn't interfere because 343 is
making the contra for that game so like
i mean there you can have the debate you
know whether or not 343 should
continuously be in charge of halo and
that's a debate we can have yeah but i
don't think
certain infiniti making the battle
royale is going to really affect what i
agree with halo
i think it works but let me say there's
one thing about the mode itself me and
my boy sean 786 was talking about this
the other day
if this mode is true with which it looks
like it is
yeah the driving do you think they need
to
have more traditional driving like hold
the right trigger to accelerate because
the halo controls with the you know with
the vehicles that's you know that's for
the hardcore halo fans you know we're
used to it but it's not really that easy
to appeal to a bigger audience do you
think they're going to have to change
the way you drive you know like like
your vehicle that's a good one what do
you guys think
what's
um and it comes back that the the test
group likes the new advanced driving
mode uh different controls yeah it'll
probably go in that direction or they
can probably give you the ability to use
whichever driving style that you like so
right okay interesting yeah no doubt let
me get away on this whole battle royal
thing because there is attic is right
there
i don't think there's a lot of pushback
but i have seen some
that you know
halo should stay away from this they
should not have a battle royale mode you
know where you at with this whole thing
oh i'm a halo nut right so
i don't really believe it needs it but
if it's done but it has to be oh you're
one of them old schools
i don't want sprint
okay okay okay ads you're not one of
those that's like don't put ads in the
game right now
okay okay that don't even make sense you
don't aim down sights there's a problem
but
i think it has to be done correct
because halo is not one of them games
with attachments and you know shields
and they would really have to change
how halo is what halo is based on the
game
so
you know
it would be nice because i'm a battle
royale dude okay i play fortnite pub g
apex warzone that those you see you see
what i post on yeah for sure
yeah yeah so
but halo is my favorite game
that is the game for me and if you do it
you gotta change a lot to fit
what battle royale brings it's not you
just can't say a bunch of people on the
map and everybody just do what they want
to do that don't work everybody who has
done who has copied pub g has put a spin
on it good party fortnite fortnite has
put building
zone they change where you put
attachments on the guns and you know you
find the different weapons and everybody
brought some to the table even apex yeah
we said oh apex came from titanfall but
that don't play like titanic they don't
play like titanfall right they put their
own spin on it so facts it's just really
intriguing to me to see what they would
do with halo in a battle royal and
i guess i'm not a visionary because i
can't see it okay
so for the record
by the way you're not opposed but you're
just you're you're concerned is
structurally from a gameplay standpoint
right how do they execute it that it
still feels like halo
halo but in a battle raw
situation because
that's gonna be difficult
okay last question for both of y'all
open it up back to the laws what about
from a player count standpoint this is
another debate do we see
like let's just say for example
it's
20 or 30 or less as opposed to a scope
of a 50 or 100. well it has to be higher
than big team battle okay what's like
right it would have to be higher than
big team battle point at least 60
players 50 players therefore it didn't
feel like a battle royale if it's not is
that an l
for 108 and dirt
yes
so so the question is if it's 30 players
is that a l yes yes because it needs to
be bigger than that okay absolutely
then just spend your money somewhere
else
so y'all renegade so there's a there
like i said i don't think halo needs it
but i do think in order to compete on a
scale they want to they're going to have
to have it but
that's not competing like you literally
took what everyone else does and you did
it worse so hypothetically
if the player so what what is the
minimum play account for this paddle
that is pro battle royale to be
satisfied minimum 100 wow
[Laughter]
i'm 90 right
all the time oh you flexing all your
stats
i told you dudes that this was coming
you know the rumors is kicking him and
dude it's like maybe i've seen it fall
across the rainbow
whatever man i told you it was coming
anyway they're getting that bag they're
going that right after that and this is
the perfect ip to do that you have odst
uh soldiers there um
if you actually get the the battle pass
and you actually work your way up to get
a master chief with extra overshield or
something like that in the game then
that that happens
um
there's ways for them to to to do it to
make it uh popular okay uh paramount is
throwing tons of cash in the way of the
halo franchise
so again
when you have uh movie money
funneling into your iep
that can facilitate
millions of different things that that
thing can uh grow into i told you battle
royale was definitely one of them after
i've seen the success of pub g and
fortnite apex dozens of war zones um
they have the ip that can do it it's a
military based ip
why not and anybody that doesn't like
battle royale just don't play it stay
yourself right over there
you know and it doesn't it it's like
your butthole nobody needs to hear it
all right so we don't need to hear your
opinion or see it if you don't care
about it you don't care about it don't
click like on it don't pick it up don't
talk about it and don't bring it about
just you know how you really show you
don't care about something don't talk
about it
if you don't care about something
because that shows that you really care
okay right
when when people say i don't want it and
it should never be there and that's
something that i will never nobody cares
right
and if you really didn't care about it
you wouldn't talk about it listen
it should be options and we should have
more options all over the place the
problem is people with these little
minds and these little scopes want
things that only fit just for them
battle royale and you got a halo segment
of the population that wants that to
happen right i'm one of them
all right so the arena base i've
outgrown that arena crap
i want the last man standing i want the
trophy i want the crown on my head i
want that chicken dinner i agree with
you yes
do you want master chief emoting when
the chicken dinner yes i do you want him
doing the doughnuts
with a sticky leg i'm going to pay for
the sticky like back the thing is the
thing
what await with that is but but here
here it is
he's done it already
regardless what people want from halo if
they don't want him doing
whatever these dances are people doing
these days
they don't want to be doing stuff like
that that's irrelevant at that point
because if if you're not competing with
them then you're not going to beat them
and one of the biggest things that's in
these games is emotes apex legends has
emotes too if i believe correctly like
overwatch has had emotes for a while
like okay like
people
okay we've seen
we seen
a kratos
cosmetic on fortnite do some dances not
that point
it is what it is but super addict that
that is not in their own ip
they gave the license to say get ahead
you could do that but now this is home
yo man doing the stinky leg across the
street when you gave the ip up for the
goat why should you care if you're doing
a stinky leg in your house all right
kate i got another counter for you what
about those who say
this game came out
it's a fantastic game but ton of lack of
content where are the maps where's the
for the core hardcore they're going to
say how dare you king talk about battle
royale when this is
suffering from maps contact no co-op no
forge and you got the nerve to be talked
about some other bowl let me say
something real quick you know what i
tell them they they have you know
obviously xbox got lack of content they
have a lack of vision
because if they if they don't want that
what's better for the franchise look
like sure
there is some issues that i'm pretty
sure
he's working on some but if they
no but see the thing is they're still
working on it like another complete
studio is making this fair
do we think that adding another two to
three hundred people working for three
four three is gonna help the matter no
probably adding more people is gonna
make it worse
okay
plus plus like let's not forget xbox
hasn't announced anything yeah that is
true that's why i say this i say i got
one more question
that's complaining that halo doesn't
have content and halo doesn't have maps
and halos
halo massive collection numbers or steam
or highlights all of this everything
everything all that stuff go play
something else
take your time someplace else take your
talents to south beach
[Laughter]
go ahead let me let me say something
again first of all
rainbow six siege when it came out did
we heard the same thing right that is
true that is true
it grew yeah
all it had was building mode facts right
good point
what it is today
that wasn't what it was
okay yeah um
these games are built with longevity in
mind you're not gonna get all the bells
and whistles we're a little spoiled out
here right oh look at fortnite look at
look at apex apex was apex for months
yeah for a long time but it was live
service these games need space to grow
we this is not no
hit it hit it hit it and hit it and done
you know what i'm saying like it's like
they have vision they have
we're not getting everything up front
yeah everybody want
like me i went out there i beat these
battle passes i beat i beat the the
seasons and i go in there every tuesday
like damn i got a new armor to get but
guess what it's not there
because i
i do a marathon on the game
everybody's not doing marathons yes it
needs some more maps okay you can
complain about maps but content
this is a competitive multiplayer game
you playing it for the maps or you plan
it to be number one because i played it
to be the number one and that's what's
wrong with this community
[Laughter]
man
i could count on the amount of times on
my hand how many times i've walked into
that ranked match because i'm just not
like oh that's same old but
but i just i it's just like look man
we've been playing br start since halo 1
halo 2. like i ain't trying to play none
of these tryhards people have these
modded controllers
it's just like no like some of these
people are that good but it's just like
i'm not trying to play a game for me to
go crazy
so it's like i want to just play halo
for halo and and i'm sorry but part of
that is the map so i mean if you look at
it like how many times have you
what is the number one thing people talk
about multiplayer man that guardian was
lit that pit was lit like people don't
talk about you remember the time in in
halo 2 that i was this ranked or that
range like people they will talk about
the maps
i just got to be real with that okay i
mean i mean that might be a point but
you know you sound a little casual
oh
i want to be number one i want to be
looking down at you
because i believe the bodies unfolded
okay
fair now my question to you what a way
would you be upset
if battle royale comes out before
new arena maps and content come out
yes okay now okay because this is what
the fans want we want more maps okay
we're standing taller it's like it's
like battlefield everybody's complaining
about in battlefield
that's not battlefield players but
you're not complaining about what
matters the most the game has no
communication until next tuesday yeah
you can't talk in the game no this is
why you know the hardcore it's not
speaking because
you have to communicate what game
launches nowadays besides nintendo that
has no sorry
i'm sorry
why i had to take it straight oh
when you hear people complaining about
battlefield
oh it's it's too pretty it doesn't look
like you're in a battlefield but
nobody's saying the truth it has no
voice communication
playing on the switch oh for sure i know
for sure that's what the hardcore want
we want to be able to talk to our
teammates yo bring that spawn point so
we can keep coming back to the side of
the map and not walking or have to wait
for vehicles
this is what you need okay so when you
hear from the hardcore this is the
competitive nature
we want to win
good matches
but we want to win that's it when i play
2k i'm trying to beat you about 50. i
ain't trying to be nice
yeah forget it
um last thing i think dirk made a
fantastic point before i jump in um
what about we didn't really talk i
didn't want to talk about this except
dirk like what about the
the presence of vehicles like you know
we we know that was it fortnite doesn't
even know
yeah i'm sorry
right so like how do you i'm gonna pose
this to addicting dirt like addict like
how do you
feel about like the warthog maybe the
scorpions being in there like how could
they implement it to make it like
exactly how they did war zone on halo 5.
make some tweaks make it uh control
better and put them in there like look
like people was like oh you got to fix
the you got to fix the
the way that the
the vehicle is drive they've been
driving like this since halo one if you
think they're going to change now where
where what game you've been playing but
to dirt's point though
this is a new audience a casual trying
to reach trying to read so maybe maybe
you get a middle ground maybe both you
get a middle ground where there's an
option to change the vehicle i think
they should have options because there's
a lot of fortnite dudes gonna come in
and they're gonna be like what's going
on
how do i drive this vehicle
i don't agree because i do feel like at
one point you have to keep it a little
bit on the core of what halo is right
like i don't want them making a a battle
royale if they're going to start
changing up gameplay mechanics like
obviously you have to put stuff into the
halo battle royale to make sense to a
battle royale but if you start changing
the gameplay and the foundation halo's
built on i don't want that because
people
realistically want you to jump from one
game to another okay because they're
going to want to get the people from the
battle royale be like yo we got arena
they're going to want to keep cycling
those players through but if you're if
you're playing battle royale in in the
driving mechanics is different than
playing the regular arena then i feel
like you're going to have missed hiccups
there people are going to get be
confused now and maybe if they have like
a the default and you could switch it to
a you know a different setting
you know resemble something like
fortnite maybe we could do something
like that but i don't want the default
being that because i feel like
everyone's got to be able to play the
game the way halo was meant to be played
and if you want to play the other arena
i want that transition to be seamless
okay now fair enough and um
these are great points i think
you guys are definitely
making the strong argument that it it
should exist and it should come through
and it should reach a whole player base
but let's be real it's it's generational
you know a lot of us here yeah minus the
young wolf you know you know come from
that not that addict doesn't but you
know what i'm saying like that that's
the arena stuff that they like they
don't want other stuff some people come
from from our from our generation but i
do think it is necessary because you got
to bridge the gap
any ways
you can get this younger generation and
let's be real they're playing these
free-to-play games they're playing this
battle royale that's and here's the
other thing the streamers right the
streaming community you know how big
these games are so as long as cert i'd
actually i'll be honest i like the fact
that certain affinity is doing it
because it reminds me of destiny when
destiny was struggling to make content
at one time they had to when they were
under activision they had to outsource
they had high moon studios they had
vicarious vision making content stuff
like that so it's one of the i'm with
attic like it's one of the situations
you can walk into bubblegum the same
time if you have these other entities
making that content now i will say what
108 is saying is very true
it's got to be good
and it's gotta it's gotta retain
a feel of halo on some level it may not
be exact but i do like the idea of
vehicles i do like the idea of earning
maybe the power ups or whatever whatever
i like the data mind leaks because now
they talk about we could squad up like
how we used to do in p pub g king like
we could four deep you know what i'm
saying you don't you could do duos you
could do fours i like those type of
options i saw the bot thing which is
cool because let's be real you know what
i'm saying not everybody you know as far
as the player count maybe that have a
full server 100
as far as the numbers that the players
i'm torn because there's a part of me
that's like yo
i want that 100. you know what i'm
saying i want that like
you know like could you imagine like
just you know everybody's podcast
dragons then
you know wbg iop you know xbox oh name
every podcast bla yo this is my i will
pay money to re i still get mad at game
companies with battle royale like i
would pay money like how battlefield
used to do it and you rent a server and
be like yo i want my 100 you know
whoever to come in this is just the guys
i want and we could go out and get that
you know a massive cheap chicken dinner
yeah
fire that'd be a thing so i'm for it man
i'm for it i'm glad it's happening i
think longevity like all again went away
said is key because
this thing has to continue to exist and
kenny were right you've always said this
thing was going to be a live service
you've always said listen you said it it
was hiding in plain sight by the name
you said infinite you said and people
didn't pay attention to you when you
said that you put that out there and a
lot of people resistance the hardcore
was very resistant to you people they
gotta take it [ __ ]
right over here that's it
[Laughter]
last thing i want to say shout out to
certain affinity um this is an example i
don't think xbox is getting enough
credit we've seen examples like this
with certain affinity we've seen
avalanche where xbox is doing this thing
now where they're not just signing you
off like they're having this
relationship you're right organic
right that they've been making halo
content for a long time this is just not
some new thing right so you got that
aspect you have these other studios that
they've been working with and they're
like yeah we're not giving you the bag
off the red let's see how things work
yeah you know what i'm saying one day
for 25 years before we say and keep them
started
out your mouth then they're going to put
a ring on your finger
they're still making um that monster
that monster hunting game yeah yeah dirk
let me ask you guys this um
they've been working with xbox on halo
games since what halo 2 they say yeah so
they've been working with them for a
while
why do you guys think they announced
their how the how their relationship is
strengthening right they announced it on
twitter officially yo we're
working with xbox we uh you know our
relationship is even deeper now yeah and
i thought that was kind of you know
different for them to announce it
with chocolates they haven't announced
it
no i'm wit no bro i'm with you i i think
it's great pr
to set up the eventual you know battle
royale itself because it's i agree there
was no need to necessarily announce that
yeah it's a need to announce in what way
breaking news is in acquisition season
they're looking out there the bill's got
the place
the owner
liked the tweet somebody said like you
know that yeah definitely yo come on
home baby xbox and he liked the tweet so
someone looking to get cuffed up okay
that's that whole thing like people keep
acting like these dudes they looking to
be a quiet like you know they are you
you like to have this the stability of a
constant check roof over your head with
your belly you know you like the
stability of that all that sitting on
the outskirts talking to independent
crap
nothing freezing you're looking like me
in the wintertime
hey do you guys remember when tim
schaefer said when xbox approached him
them
at first he was kind of reluctant then
he said you know what after they got
acquired you know they did the deal and
he said
it's so good that we don't have to shop
our games around looking for a publisher
that job security
you know man bro you
know you have a job you don't have to
shop your game am i hoping your team is
going to get paid yep that's something
man like yo i feel more crap eat hope
exactly feel your belly man like you
quickly talk about well i hope our game
gets sold
it's just like look at at the end of the
day um i do think that they
made that official announcement on
twitter for career purposes they're
they're looking to hire people true
because if you look they announced it
and they literally sent a leak to we're
hiring so i feel like
it's it's easier like if you're going
around you're doing stuff
in incognito and you're not really
announcing that you're working on
something like halo
not as a lot of people
as many more people as you want would
actually apply but if you go out there
and you say yo we're working on a game
that you've been playing for 20 years
and a lot of people are coming out of
college they're like we're hiring so i
feel like that was the point it's like
look we're looking on halo working on a
new project with halo we want more
people to join our team and i think
that's why they did that yeah
all i will say in fairness to the people
who are against i do want 343 to to
deliver on these promises though that
they because you know it's it's i'm
listen we do dabs work hard but they are
a big studio there's a lot of money
behind that game
content needs to happen so we will see
absolutely what's going on i agree with
you you know what i'm saying but we're
going to move on super chats i got a
help me out so i got from the angry
therapist md i don't know if i missed
anyone before that so help me out he
says find out super chat shout out to
dirt you already know
oh we got a returning
member for king
free r kelly ten dollars
it's too late for halo infinite addict
oh he coming for attic what you feel
you feel stupid you only show up every
other week so i think it's a little too
late for you all you always just show up
when something happens
what's going on there do you only got
the money to super chat on good weeks is
it every other week
you got tired of me beating the brakes
off for you bro
don't do them like that you know that's
got hands too you better be careful dude
shout out oh shout out to skew lord skew
mike ask you julia 10 super chat halo at
least will have it as an option i'm
hearing killzone is coming back as only
a battle royale and that could be one of
the ten games as services i prefer
options i heard that you ain't gonna get
no options you're gonna get what they're
gonna give you you're gonna take it and
you're gonna like it at least that's the
whole day what else is like where the
games doing they ain't doing nothing
else might as well do something but they
did put out their game they need to fix
it up though
[Laughter]
let's keep it a stack
nobody under 40 is holding out for halo
infinite battle royale can't save this
game microsoft took it out they had the
chance
and they dropped the bag back in
december well he would know
nobody listen he wouldn't know about the
age under 40.
oh
[Laughter]
my
somebody check on him man check on him
make sure he goes
yo
man you got the key to it you still got
the key to ignition on the super chat
though much love brother what's up
that was hard i was on i go for a kick
that was hard it flew over my head at
first
[Laughter]
cooper xbox can make all star br shoot
with halo gears car doom and overwatch
crossover i would call it xbox legends
okay i don't i don't i'm not feeling the
name but i that is a pretty unique thing
that only xbox can do they could do like
an apex legend a looter shooter like
like um like battle royale i like i i
like that i like that maybe not luda
sure i mean i'm a hero uh shooter yeah
uh then we got a
a fight out superman from victor
great show and happy easter iop oh thank
you brother what's good dirt 108 what's
happening addict and call
hello appreciate you appreciate your
support from splendidness uh
[Music]
he the prince okay i don't know what
that's about maybe maybe maybe people
darker skate could understand that joke
i don't know
like let's not be acting like i don't be
reading some of these super chats use
like you a little bit too light
it
[Laughter]
about to power up with that powder and
smack some fools in the halo br got that
powder get that gg.com you know what i'm
saying go to i very get cold iron lord
get that tip some of that sound with
that powder get it you got a 30 super
trap from t kyries um whatever man
in this series um
we're moving past that the movement
again it would be
lovely they made a mode like supremacy
from star wars where you are the
covenant banished in unsc but have a
third party between which ai controlled
and is either the float or the sentinels
that's actually sounds good
next time you struggle with a name just
call them lamonius
he kept
i gotta get the holy paris gotta restart
my joint give me one second all right
here we go here we go so paris shout out
to the lord of xbox microsoft game
streaming and xcloud he says twilight
super chat yo great show
what up dragon i heard
battle royale
what if bungie made a destiny battle
royale would y'all like that galley's
galore
battle royals are good for business i
asked the first one with you brother i
actually think they're the few studio
that could do about a royale imagine
like you pick you finding a pickup
that's like oh man it's the last word
you know what i'm saying like yeah
exotics exotics would be fire now the
question the only thing is we got to see
because destiny has a lot of abilities
like would you be able to do a an oval
in the gym like
make that be drops too you came down as
a lightless guardian you have to find
the okay you could put find a super you
could find the abilities too
yeah like you start off a billy lee list
that would be fine that would be that
honestly could work i like that that was
a good idea let's look at the lord paris
xbox microsoft
now the question is is he doing that
because he got inside him yeah listen
man if that you know they they'll drop
an article real quick
we're going to get this before it goes
away you got a 23 month message from
scrub nurse shout out to the lords and
of course my brother lemon we got a link
back up on the podcast for sure we got a
22 message from the man who get these
horns
cog be pushing that powder my uncle uh
my great uncle got 20 years before your
powder too
this is positive powder y'all this is
positive
we're moving a different kind of weight
out here so relax
[Laughter]
but this is the
chat right now go get that temp set off
you don't see it cold out loud go there
go get that so we all caught up
yeah yeah all right no doubt let's get
into this last actually one more two
more so we got um yeah this is king's
topic man um can i set you up big shift
right now in the in the gaming industry
and game subscription services shout out
to games industry dot biz
sony and nintendo both to update
subscription guidelines those both
platform holders join microsoft's effort
to update online services following the
cma's investigation so basically it
looks like um there is an investigation
on all subscription services regarding
auto renewal
practices
sony has agreed to implement new
measures for playstation plus
subscribers which includes contacting
long-term customers that haven't used
their service for a while to remind them
how to cancel subscriptions if users
don't cancel the service but aren't
actively using it so they will stop
taking payments nintendo has also
altered its business practices its
nintendo switch online service will no
longer be sold with automatic renewal
set as the default option if users wish
to turn it on they need to do so after
signing up so this is after both sony
nintendo after microsoft agreed to
change the way it presents its
information to game pass on subscribers
in january they call microsoft pledge to
new terms that clearly display
information on the membership including
the price how to cancel it how to get a
refund king this is a great topic i
didn't even know this was going on so
break it down and why are you smiling
the best things in life is free
information is fantastic for people
tried to tell people a long time ago
microsoft is for the people's
they didn't wasn't nobody came to them
and said yo you need to change this
right now
um this right here is a bad practice
you know how many times do you have
subscription services that you forgot
that you even had hitting your bank
account yeah you know how about that guy
that hit that bank account and he was
overdraft you know now you got 35 on top
of your 15 dollars for your netflix
that's why these dudes be scared of game
pads
that bill could that recover and come up
and hit you at the wrong time of the
week
don't do them like
like yo listen man how did you let this
happen you let this happen
and then you call sony you like you i
need my money back it's only like no
backseat son
no backseat
microsoft has put this in place ahead of
time and what they didn't do see um the
article tells you they were doing this
in europe microsoft is doing it
worldwide
all right they're implementing that
whole structure worldwide
where sony and nintendo's like yo that's
free duck son i don't care what nobody
say that they ain't take it off they
joint that's their problem this is my
money and they've been hitting y'all for
a long time it happened to me with the
playstation they renewed i tried to like
do um
because i i forgot that they
they multiplayer wasn't free anymore
right so i had to pay for the
multiplayer so i can play uh um
hip-hop gamer
inside the game right for the
playstation plus or whatever the hell
that that they needed paid for to play
him played him forgot that this is
automatic default yeah on um
on renewal
the next month they was right in my
wallet son and i'm like what is this
playstation
i didn't order anything and i went and
was description so again
they got the free bucks for me because i
wasn't using it they could tell when you
interacting with your stuff i'm happy
that this is happening right now take
away the free money give it right back
to the people so the people that are
current can't be abused any longer
because that's abuse if they're not
using your service they shouldn't be
charged for your service you can tell if
it's i see this is where the language is
ambiguous
after a period of time
how long is that period of time one year
nine months
you know and you have to give a
definitive piece of time
after 30 days if you haven't activated
the service we will take you off for
autonomatic renew right before
the
next renewal you know so you have to be
very careful with the language in it
because they could still go through that
loophole but again this can only benefit
everyone i and i
i don't know how many times has happened
to me
until i can look at my bill how many
times does it happen to y'all guys no
it's real talk
dirt what's your date bro
um
i didn't know nothing about this until
right now also um yeah i i think it's
cool man um
uh i didn't realize
this whole topic and i didn't realize
xbox was actually doing that you know um
you know because that the fight because
like
the average person they just signed up
they don't like like he said next month
he was like oh
yeah so you know like the average person
they don't really
check on that and i think it's fair and
i think it's good customer service to
say yo
they're taking away that as the default
option um you know and just you know
if you really like our service you will
continue to subscribe and you have to
you know check on it and make sure that
you click the right option to continue
to subscribe so so i think it's cool but
you know
not fair enough fair enough
lord
108 dragons tv
where we at man auto renewing
subscription services everybody seems to
be jumping on board now that the uh
competition and what is it marketing
authority is kind of uh involved now so
what's your thoughts on it listen it's
good business practice i'm gonna deal
with the story real quick let's go uh uh
uh you know some things you paid through
paypal
i don't look at the paypal bill right
i was getting hit three times
in one month for twenty four dollars wow
and i don't never when i get my oh it's
your paypal state remember like yeah i'm
probably buying them through paypal
for about a year
wow they was getting me so this is good
business practice and and um like
microsoft started in europe then they
turned it worldwide yeah so listen this
is good business practice you know i
don't want i don't want things to order
renewal and you don't want things
already new that you don't want to if it
ain't netflix
and or amazon prime or something listen
get out my wallet
you know what i'm saying so this is this
is great this is great for the consumer
at the end of the day
um it's good that the other two
companies is picking it up because
microsoft took the lead on it so it's
it's good you know what i'm saying no
that's a fantastic i wish i could have
got all that money
i wish this the cma was took care of me
because i'm like yo y'all didn't you
know they did send me the statements but
it was the same company hitting me three
times
same company hit me three times so it's
good no doubt you already know i got a
lot of the money back no that's what's
up lord addict what are we thinking
about this auto renews subscription
services
i don't care
you good with it you go with it leave it
on leave it on burn through
like to be honest with you when it comes
to that like you know then i'll just
stop using your service if you're gonna
force me to renew or anything like that
it's just like look you ain't forcing me
to do anything i can assure you that
like you ain't no like it ain't
happening you might think it's gonna
happen but then you just see poof addict
has left the building
i'll jump in it was interesting to me
because um yeah shout out to king for
bringing this to my attention i did not
notice half went down and um i think
like i said it's good
consumer protection right it's good to
to understand like because i think what
it is is we since the even though this
is not one-to-one like loot boxes or
anything like that i think what people
are realizing is how lucrative gaming
can actually be and people having these
subscription services on you know is
definitely something that they need to
be aware of the only thing i find
interesting
i don't know keig if i don't know the
details i don't want to comment fully
but i don't know if all three
corporations
were initially willing to be like oh
okay like as opposed to someone checking
the books and like oh what's going on
here why what's happening here yeah why
is there no option to turn this off
because they have a federal regulations
uh
bureau
that was like looking at that aspect of
it right and the reoccurring charges and
stuff like that and
i think microsoft just took the the lead
ahead of time right before the
repercussions came down right because
you know they make big deals you know
you know they're doing activision
they're doing bethesda
they're not doing like you know bungees
and little deals and stuff like that
trying to cry
[Laughter]
so my man came
so they gotta have the the the the
appearance of of uh
this is pocket watching talk
[Laughter]
[Music]
listen dirt shout out to your video your
video had me dead that's right we got
beating our knees the last generation
i'm not taking my foot off your throat
thank you
anyway petty
[Laughter]
king has been supremely messy that's
funny stuff man anyways that's all i got
on there but that is good every day
homie good stuff for the community and
make sure y'all check y'all auto renewal
please
because it's all done overdraft will
check it for you
ridiculous no doubt checking it right
now
uh-huh yeah check make sure y'all check
man or no yo hold on is that the
wondering dutch from the midweek mix-up
is that is that he is that him just want
to make sure his levels is good make
sure we him hopefully he getting his
situation corrected while we take care
of these super chats and he'll be out
real quick
i'm looking now while we do that how we
do it i can actually get some merch
which we missed
actually the building dutch let me check
your level sir how you sounding
yeah should be sound good yes there we
go
we got a five dollar superstar clutch
man zero one thinking about grabbing
that x screen i'll always be on the
airport with a little man do any of you
have it or what are your thoughts is the
screen nice pretty sure cog has one i
got that no i got the experience it's
fantastic i'm gonna be bringing it to
pax east with the homies so y'all can
check it out i'm just gonna be bringing
my um my google um what's your favorite
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and 108 you better bring that
little setup you had i was fired that
you put on twitter yeah i saw that i saw
that yeah talk to the people so we can
see it
then we have the surface duo too
wonderful phone wonderful game pass x
cloud okay okay okay
okay
i see you guys
smelly wrestling geek okay
shout out to him
what do you think of the odd world
soul storm developers saying that the
game be on playstation plus being
devastating to the game cells
i mean i can tell you that real quick i
can tell you that i mean there's no
surprise to me you know like you
understand um
it's dead over there like
if a tree if a tree falls in the forest
do you really hear it did it really
happen
in the middle of the city
you know what goes on over here
yeah you know everybody that's inside
game pass they stuff is looking
luxurious baby you're over there i don't
know man your man came out i was like yo
i don't know what's going on are you
implying that the services are not equal
as far as what developers are getting
i'm implying the bag ain't right
something looking good
i do think that after we talk about this
yeah you know
since we got since we got dirt griggity
and we got 108 and i'm pretty sure you
said someone else just joined
oh dutch just showing man i think we
need to you know reminisce a little bit
talk about how xbox has been winning
these mpd's
that's the final topic but we'll get to
what's going on but before we go let me
get on the thing i didn't yeah
i love this he's messy today
can we flavor addiction
shout out to um i think the information
happened on um xcp and then it goes to
those guys so um look
i'm with king on the simple fact that
you know that happened it did happen on
the playstation plus situation right as
far as you know where he put that out
now
the thing from my understanding is he
got a bag from playstation to help
complete the game right so that that was
the first detail that i think a lot of
things missed second of all so if that
doesn't happen it doesn't happen you
don't necessarily come out then the
other thing is it's how you negotiate
your back from my understanding from
game pass you cuz he's mad because he
got a he said he's got millions and
millions of downloads but he didn't see
that bread he didn't see that money so
my thing is you're supposed to negotiate
your royalties because
you're saying you're saying
yeah
guys he thought he was only going to get
50 000
yes
so what exactly so what's happening is
you in my opinion not to be found you
can't complain now when you ain't
putting your contract on your streaming
numbers and you're downloading you're
supposed to negotiate you're gonna leave
it up to me
no no no no no no no no no
okay to your point i don't know the
structure of playstation plus deal
nobody knows the show
it's one to you are correct it's one of
the two it's either a you didn't
negotiate your bag on your download
because you supposed every download
you're supposed to get a royalty at
least that's what we hear from xbox
stuff people uh
yeah or
the contract over there is not set up
that way that you just not getting that
you maxed out at fifty thousand
[Laughter]
yo he signed a 360 deal
don't do him like that not the 360 deal
that's a bad recognition
you reckon that jerking your record
[Laughter]
he was happy they gave him that advance
he was like oh do you think he was happy
he's like i'm in the building
million four million with my money and
and that's why i i i
wanna i wanna yeah somebody gotta
publish it that's a fact
that's why i tell people to kind of pump
the brakes on those oh you see this is
why subscription services are bad that's
the specifics of his deal whether it be
negotiating absolutely or what was
offered you don't have to sign something
that you don't like and you need to
anticipate you need to hopefully be able
to anticipate what the projections are
for your particular game so that's where
i stand on it but it's a great question
i was thinking about bringing up but
everybody doesn't talked about it on
sunday but i'm glad we got this super
chat in anyway anyway moving on you know
what i'm saying so what else we got we
got sku who we got um after smelly
wrestling
oh okay i gotta skew fight out super
chat king got sony fans catching shots
like ricky from boys in the hood okay oh
wow ricky okay
game of thrones by choice
put a link up in there we got to get
that link yeah put here put something up
there let's see where that says you're
dropping that link right there oh bro
paris just hooked you all up y'all
better have grabbed that game pass trial
offer xbox is in the building y'all
better
no granted no overdrive
shout out to you with the overdraft
protection shout out to lord paris man
thank you brother much love good to see
you in the realm we appreciate it gamer
by choice 10 hour super chat you all are
an all-star podcast loving the show need
to do it more often salute thank you
thank you so much it's the guest that
makes us high 108 one wondering dutch
dirt everybody pulling up for us in the
last minute really appreciate it so i
think that is that shout out to the
gamer perspective hold on i gotta shout
out lognet in the building you have to
negotiate for how successful you think
your title will be based on that the
factual you are y'all are saying that
homeboy okay because this was his his
his thought process right he don't have
that many playstations out there
i'm thinking
that's what he said that's what he said
that's what he said okay he said you
know they didn't have that many
playstation fives out there so my joint
is gonna come out he's gonna do x amount
of this that in the third i think he got
bamboozled on the hustle side and and
when it launched
he didn't understand all right well i'm
going to get paid by the download he was
like yo do you want the bag up front or
do you want to get paid on the back end
it's like give me all my bread up front
homie so he didn't have faith in his
joint you know when you have faith in
your music you have faith in any product
do you understand you say give me the
back end i want the money at the gate
and i want the pay-per-view revenue
that's what i'm looking for i don't care
about that appearance and fee i don't
want that you keep that give me the back
end money
well now the backing came in real high
and now you're looking over like
everybody else brought lamborghinis and
you sit over here
with the tesla
she was balling when you brought that
tesla up front but who's got the money
on the back end so like you said
negotiations in the contract i i just
think microsoft has structured theirs
differently
that it wouldn't have been as
devastating to him
if he released it inside game pass
well now they got options so look at
your options homie not for real shout
out to gaming perspective he's dropping
bars this is the home team he said um he
signed his deal before the game delay
that's true the game did delay and he
screwed up his numbers he said i feel
him on that his numbers were based based
on launch week instead of months after
launch again that's the deal man it's
the deal right
he signed yeah shout out to taymor uh a
ship should be a positive
mispronounce your name damn i think
that's three dollar australian damn this
is cool shout out to king my favorite
console fan
oh
that's what's up yo thank you you know i
do prefer xbox and if you uh don't know
now you know
if you didn't know
supposedly the deal was only for a
hundred thousand downloads wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
they could not sign that deal fast
enough and slipped it right back to
homeboy here you go you good
everything's good
you know how when you finesse somebody
you check to make sure that are you high
you are you go home boy how are you good
yo i'll catch you later all right
bye-bye
oh man bessie
we are going to move on to the final
topic and i gotta touch in the middle so
i'm glad he's here for this uh march
european sales data you know what i'm
saying so shout out to games industry
dot biz oh real quick shout out to gamer
by choice remember for 30 months this
show has the perfect amount of news and
comedy on this easter sunday iop wgb 108
salute and don't forget midway mix
update in the building here too so
salute them as well
bro yeah man so look you know we've got
the uh numbers for europe came out that
was pretty interesting shot the benji
sales shout out to games industry that
biz so on hardware looks like switch is
number one on the platform xbox series
and playstation 5. game games industry
biz goes on to say stock shortages
continue to hold back xbox playstation
but it's a strong month for nintendo
switch with sales up year or year over
14.2 million games were sold all across
the board a rise of over 34 compared
with march so it looks like from the
standouts eldon ring gran turismo kirby
and wwe shine across europe so elder
ring is the number one game for a second
month in a row continues to be a major
seller on digital download stores xbox
live psn steam accounting for 69
sony's gran turismo 7 king in a
comfortable second position on the
podium play arcade racers uh-huh just
someone said it was flopping but
listen someone said number so second on
the playset
the new release title actually sold best
at physical retail with box copies
accounting for 58 of the sales the ps5
second place the second ps5 version of
the game they gotta buy it in your
opinion but the facts in europe say
otherwise the ps5 version of the game
was the most pop
the feel let me finish the day of grand
theft auto the ps5 version of the game
was the most popular representing 64
of all copies sold with the remainder on
playstation if you're not number one
you're the first loser oh my god you're
ridiculous second place don't count
nobody remembered you
any way finishing right out the um the
numbers as far as the software grants
freeze both seven second fifa fifa sorry
22 third or gta 5 for kirby forgotten
land in the fifth spot wwe 2k 22-6
horizon from where seven dropped out of
seven
um pokemon
stupid [ __ ] why you gotta get the
extra on that they dropped out of the
top ten and now you not mention it all
oh not the eat the boss cobble i mean
that's the take over bars oh pokemon
arceus i don't know what that is that's
after acting for the attack on that
eight uh f1 2021 nine and then right now
running out the tenth spot is tiny tina
wonderland so interesting yes yeah
like they're
the the one that's like three like 3d
pokemon yeah but
yeah it didn't appeal to me in case you
ain't noticed i didn't review it yeah i
could see you there so yeah then the
last couple of things they say our
places stock walls continue as far as
europe starts 232 000 game consoles were
sold and then um they still they did
well in accessories and then they'd also
talk about how you know xboxes they sell
the flaps to the wings the most they got
the most wing flaps
[Laughter]
in the month of february they had the
most wing flaps
anyway so look dutch man up into a swim
gym we got you in the building europe in
the building you know what i'm saying my
european brothers over there so like
what what do you feel about this data
what are the things that kind of stand
out to you from this um from from the
european watch sales
yeah it's um it's to be honest it is it
is exactly how it is over in europe um
the the actual availability of of xbox
consoles now is is pretty much stable i
would say
um to the point where you can literally
pick up any xbox series s or xbox series
x for that matter pretty much at will
now yeah um
it's it's it does sell out but then it's
back in stock game within a dsl um so
it's it's much more rapidly replenished
than it ever was so i think they've
pretty much got on top of it now
um playstation on the other hand they'll
still still haven't got on top of their
stock issues
um one of the game stores near mia went
into it and said yeah we do get them in
quite frequently but they don't last
like but we don't get many in either
okay um
the stores over here much like i think
i've heard over in the us as well
they spread the the stock very thinly
between stores okay four ps fives
um it's exactly the same yeah they get
maybe to get five in or something like
that at a time wow wow
like this is launch week five it's like
little minimum amounts
like five in at a time
replenish them relatively quickly as
well so
um it's starting to get better um but
playstation definitely still haven't
gotten top of it yet right it's
it shows though the the smartness of the
decisions by xbox to produce a smaller
less powerful console
that was far cheaper and uh much easier
to produce
um on a on a mass production scale
for obviously for the die sizes um
getting getting two uh series s out of
uh one die size series x yeah that's big
which is a massive thing for them
because obviously it means that even if
they can't mass produce the series x um
because of issues that can most
definitely get on top uh of the of the
the little man
a little bit referenced
a little bit we put a little bit that
for the crew definitely getting
definitely gotten on top of that and you
know what it is i think it's we at iron
lord podcasts don't advocate you getting
on top a little man
[Laughter]
relax yourself kid relax
[Laughter]
we got respect for a little bit out here
for the little vanity check continue
touch yeah it's uh it's you know it is
it's it is the perfect companion console
though for people with a playstation as
well and that's what i think a lot of
people don't don't assume like if you
get outside of the whole twitter
fanboy console area mentality and you go
into the casual realm like people will
pick up something that is cheap um oh
the new xbox oh it's only 250 pounds
right okay i'm getting one yeah because
it's there and it's cheap and it's
available and like i knew uh the my um
my sister's new partner actually met him
for the first time yesterday
um and the first thing he said he looked
at the xbox and he was like i literally
just picked up the series x just for
halo wow
like that's like i've and he said i
don't game but i wanted halo so i picked
up a series x that's right
and it does it happens like that and i
don't like the first time i've met the
guy
nothing for nothing about him or he's
past my payment or anything like that so
it's obviously working now you know he's
smart with money the only thing the only
thing xbox really need to improve on in
europe they still haven't got on top of
it
advertisement um
advertisement is so poor over here my
playstation absolutely dominate the ads
really um all over all over bush
shelters it's like
horizon zero dawn or even if it's death
strand and whatever the new game is that
comes out it's all over the place
xbox nothing you'll be looking to see an
advert on tv wow um
let me let me ask you this because this
is another thing i want to ask you from
a european perspective is that like
i don't want to feed too much into it
but i have heard this and i want to see
if you've heard it which is
the amd in the chip situation because we
hear about the shortages we hear about
you know hey sony is having problems you
know keeping up the stock keeping supply
obviously we we talked about the
foresight with microsoft with the series
s and the die size and everything else
but some have called into question
the relationship
with amd and microsoft and there's been
a narrative i've seen
that um you know hey
because of this great relationship you
know you see his surface tablets now and
amd chips you start to see you know
i want to wait running around with you
know
amd powered by amd right now
relationship is very cozy
very cozy so you know me
do does wondering dutch lord of the do
you subscribe to this theory that
because microsoft has this great
relationship i mean the president's came
out on stage i forgot the
lovely lady that came out with um phil
during conferences with the announcement
series x will be power that's when we
got rdna too and talk going on and who
got what who didn't get what so dutch
what do you think about this sir
it's it's business at the end of the day
they made small business decisions
[Music]
that's what we're doing we do a
smartphone okay okay okay
completely paid paid for for a higher
and quicker chip output um they they
paid for for more volume
at a higher rate and they obviously did
that was small business decisions and at
the end of the day xbox were coming into
this generation intent on correcting
issues that they had in the previous
year
and that's not just on the gaming front
like they looked at things from top to
bottom and said listen this is where
we're failing and the two of the only
two things that they need to fix now
primarily we know the games are on the
way the consoles are there yes um the
two main things that you need to fix um
outside of that space is localization
and advertisements
repeat that localization brother
tell us
i just want to know who did that for you
who who's changing all these things had
wrong
i mean
are you implied that we should give
credit to uh
i mean fox's only begotten son
listen xbox only begotten son ever since
he got there everything has been
changing the skies is looking bright
everybody changes glistening a little
bit different
i'm just saying man what's his name if
if if phil dominance maximus really is
spencer
doesn't show you exactly what he about
what else do you need on this wonderful
easter sunday hey man
put your hand up and just say thank you
phil
so so back to touches so you do feel
like you said they they've made
tremendous improvements in foresight of
what went wrong with the last generation
to correct this generation but to your
points
which i think are fanta especially
localization doesn't get talked why tell
us from the european perspective why is
this so important with localization in
the advertising part
the localization advertisement
specifically is the vast majority
specifically in in central europe are
probably either unaware of xbox in the
vast majority places they don't stop
them at all
um
they
don't advertise them at all
um
and on on many occasions even forza
irwin the previous generation for the
xbox one when that launched uh he had to
drive to obviously he's in the
netherlands he had to drive to germany
to get one wow how long is that drive
but it's about four or five hours wow yo
shout out to forza earth uh he hardcore
with it wow so from a local netherlands
wow
that's like literally the equivalent of
the entire year after the the xbox
launched that they eventually started
stocking them in the netherlands wow
that puts it in perspective i mean for
for us i guess that would be like
what we say like that would be us for
the equivalent of driving to dc to get a
console
yeah boston yeah that's like us going to
boston
because we don't have an uh xbox in in
in new york city or new jersey track
like that is i'm doing it
and that's that's commonplace across
across across europe the uk i'm not
doing it after launch week
like after after like if i wasn't there
day one i don't care
it's this is a sony problem
why are we acting like it's all doom and
gloom you ain't get your money's up you
put your money in a different box that's
it you didn't walk up there and say you
listen i need more i got to get more
chips actually if y'all go back and look
at it they cut back the amount of
playstation 5 that they said that they
wanted to manufacture because the cost
of chips was too high right they didn't
value you guys getting the console so
now y'all out here upset that the the
worm has turned microsoft is now out
selling playstation and then again i'm
not a numbers dude because me personally
i only brought five of them
right and
and and and and i only opened five
playstations right so any of you dudes
that want to come at me and talk about
numbers you only brought one and you
probably don't even got one you're
probably looking at through the window
talking about when are they gonna be
available well why don't you drive your
behind to boston and go get one if you
really want something to be honest to be
honest with you
like this could actually look like did
microsoft use its funds to get ahead of
game yeah but yes sony uses his
relations with japan all the time to get
exclusive content so it's like one uses
something different and the other one
uses something else different and what's
funny is
you're seeing like mpd's like
when after month after month like i do
understand that it has a little bit to
do with the the supply restraints but
when you look at people who sit there
and the same people that say the series
s isn't selling or the same people
saying the reason that the series
consoles are selling more is because of
the series s which one is it
exactly
i agree with that man hey see the thing
is
see if i see let me say this right quick
if the xbox series x and nessa's are
sitting on shelves
right
if people are buying them what does that
mean
it means it's a desirable console people
are buying them yeah i don't care what
anybody's saying they give it away dirt
that's what it is they're giving it away
dirt
it can't there can't be interest they
can't be interest
people are gonna get more profitable for
for both sides as well because five
nanometer um chips have just started to
be
um put into production so
um the cost of of chip production is
gonna go down um it's obviously saving
in in die size anyway so
um it's
the actual overall outlay for
producing a console for both microsoft
and sony will also drop now we know sony
won't change the price
why would they yeah
they've already done a cost cut measure
and they
they didn't change the price there no
let me ask y'all a question i got a
serious question right that's what
people that move the gold post
you buy xbox series s or x
and the s is out selling the x do you
think microsoft cast
no absolutely not it's in it you're in
the ecosystem right you playing them
games
they don't care which one sells you buy
the preference of your choice i mean
i want the premium experience so you
know i still have a i still got a uh s
but they don't care where you play
that's just they want to eat
one i'll take it even one further they
don't even care if you don't buy an xbox
as long as you're on the cloud as long
as you're buying those games on pc and
you're in game pass yeah
dutch's point you know i got to give him
credit as far as foresight because king
you remember
one of the things that frustrated us
with the xbox one launch remember how
limited territories it launched
and we were like yo high on it yeah like
it was like like territories yeah did i
remember like one year two year into the
generation like yeah we just launched in
this region i'm like
yeah like two years later
when i hear dutch's story it really
resonates with forza aaron and and what
the things he'd have to do you know that
just shows you how bad the situation was
as far as from a stock perspective and
local you know as far as regional
perspective so yeah it is foresight and
as dutch said i agree with him bro
that's good business you
it's a sign of intelligence to king's
point from phil dominance maximus really
expensive is you know it's learning from
your mistakes and correcting right and
and making the necessary moves that are
improved to improve it so i have no
problem with it so i def i definitely
agree with you
i just got
one question let's go yeah so
when when sony wins npd
that's that's when these stocks is back
okay so so if they never win mpd again
the the story's going to be they don't
got enough to fight they just yeah
that's the
story i'm just telling you what the
streets are saying i got mine you know
what's crazy though like let let's talk
about
you know what we always talk about the
the beginning of a generation defines
the rest of the generation
microsoft making this
this move to you know regardless i don't
know if it's ever been officially
confirmed but let's say microsoft did
pay that money to get prioritizing like
these chips they could have low key just
help themselves win the entire
generation because what what
defines where people go towards the
middle to the end of the generation
where their friends are yes and if
microsoft making their consoles more
available than their competition at the
beginning of the generation leads to
more sales towards the end because their
friends are on that same call but they
couldn't get a playstation my girlfriend
was just talking about she's up on my
playstation she's like aj is there any
playstation 5's available i was like no
because she's been playing on one since
she wants the ps5 she's like well i
guess i'll get the xbox too like no no
hesitations whatsoever
three four years into the generation
there's a uh xbox series s slim or even
xy series x slim and people are picking
it up i'm telling you man that word of
mouth is going to continue like
my friend down the street has got xbox
uh like xbox he's playing xbox game pass
and eventually
call of duty's in there like what
did you do not to cut you did you see
that poll for people who don't have xbox
yeah activision deal goes through
foreign
yeah
that's the stream
we got to finish that statement though
[ __ ]
46 of playstation players
yeah fans
with the exclusivity or not call of duty
thing it doesn't matter the the the
value of having those games diablo iv
overwatch you know what i'm saying all
these in the game
but that's the game about that fake
loyalty
you lose me talking frailty i
give you cruelty playstation
generation was a big fan
it was the broke dude
playstation said yo we ain't putting no
cameras ringing putting these coming a
hundred dollars cheaper we gonna knock
them out the box why because they like
tcl televisions
not the hardcore dudes they they not us
us we in here we you just heard dudes
told you they would drive to a whole
nother state to get a console the casual
dude said it's not weird if it's not if
i can't order it on amazon i don't care
so
you know what i you know what i realized
it had changed a little bit is the my me
brother who is a blue collar worker
notoriously has never gamed in his life
messages the other day
a picture of his character and sea of
thieves whoa oh wow i was like
how did you get here
i was like
it was a strange and what was his
motivation
i'm curious on what the motivation is
because i'm hearing chirps even like
this on defining duke and and we'll get
write-ins from like people surprised
like people in japan like hey you know
it's catching a little bit st it's
catching steam here people are are
picking it up and the game pass there
you know kind of thing and obviously the
series that's a little man and stuff
like that but i'm just curious like for
example which you use with your brother
i know this is
not evidence we're not saying every the
whole you know saying but we are seeing
a shift right we are seeing it's not the
same like i can tell you what it wasn't
it was a friend of mine it was word of
mouth
right his friends that he worked with in
the factory um they all have xboxes
he's never notoriously gamed and was
like oh playing this game and he likes
the witcher tv series he was like i'm
going to play the witcher on there as
well okay um so he's picking up the
witcher he's playing sea of thieves he's
got like three days in sea of thieves i
was like this is a guy that's never
played and he's got game pass he was he
aware of
over and he was like you don't gameplay
to have like a headset that i can have
there it was like yeah yeah he has a
headset he has a sparkle i was like
i've got loads yeah i was like wow
nice see the word of mouth thing oh i'm
sorry yeah yeah no no it's it is percent
word of mouth and it's it was just so
strange surreal even because he's in
like the last time he gamed was when we
were probably about 12 30.
wow wow
word of mouth bringing his body
since then he's been like full
engineering like retrofitting cars and
modifying cars and working in factories
and doing hands-on work and creating
things for people but
never ever
that's that's a beautiful story let me
say this right quick word of mouth my uh
boy he's a super casual right super
casual he plays
maybe war zone and he plays maybe nba 2k
that's it every year he called me
after the axe xbox activision blizzard
announcement right call me
and he said yo dirk what's up man how's
it going bro he said hey is it true that
xbox is buying call of duty because he
knows that's all they know that's what
they call a duty vice president i don't
know who told him this but somebody told
him business people
yeah but i don't know where he found a
lot before but i talked like yeah bro
you know the deal isn't official yet but
eventually it will be and then he asked
me does that mean carter duties would be
in game pass oh
i said yeah
he was like what
that's fire bro
[Laughter]
he plays call of duty awards on that you
know like he made it right like played a
regular yearly call of duty
that's what i'm talking about
i was like yeah bro that's that's real
we know them dudes
that every year
is cod
yeah madden
that's it that's it fifa and fifa yeah
that's it that's it bro right so if you
have three-fourths of those in your
joint your surface
and you say yo
let's say it'd be one of them free r
kelly weeks you ain't got it that week
right so you're going to the joint you
go into the you go you see you in the
store
and you like damn so the xbox is okay
and low man it's 300 okay
but damn i don't got it this week oh nah
fam we got you like you hear about this
xbox all access
you can walk out right now and game
passes in the service in the call of
duty's that's out now november
right now get on this walk out the store
twitter plus every call of duty ever bro
108 you know those dudes your facts
talk to me talk to me tell me about this
thing
as old as we are we've been gaming a
long time back in the days we only had
magazines and what's your homeboys
thought of the game yes
yes
we didn't have his social media outlets
and
all this these apps and twitter bro
all we had was word of mouth yeah some
of us used to walk up to the walk up in
the store
and go on the back of the box
[Laughter]
come out and
morbius right people was like yo this is
trash or not people the critics said it
was trash i went to the movie movie was
fire
right so now i start telling people
listen in my opinion
it was a damn good movie to me
and then you go see it then you tell a
friend you tell a friend because they
initially said blade one was trash
who said one was trying so many credits
some of the critics yeah some of these
guys come back on that movie and then we
all went to the movie and was like what
about talking about the cult favorite
that's the fact
no that's a fact it was the biggest
marvel movie ever
time for his time absolutely all the
time
i want i want to i want to jump on
something that that said don't want to
wait like
i do think it behooves them to step this
market and i still feel like they should
be shouting this thing from the rooftops
like we should be seeing like billboards
like you know what i'm saying like i
know they did i think super bowl
whatever whatever but it's like i still
don't feel enough people know about game
pass in the manner it should just need
to just need a big billboard that just
says 100 plus games 10.99 yeah right but
you you know you know you don't even do
that like that's the most basic of
saying it
it shows how cost effective it is right
it's cheaper than netflix
by like over here by like seven pounds
but dutch you got you gotta put the call
of duty logo the team
we live in new york we spoil right you
go you go to the deuce yeah you'll see a
gears posted the size of godzilla you'll
see xbox and this but we in new york
correct once you leave new york correct
they got to step it up in general i
agree
especially
internationally especially plus
you see you see the warthog
yeah
yeah they gotta listen they gotta step
it up yeah wondering dutch is talking
about that's ridiculous he should he's
begging for them to advertise yeah
yeah yeah i'm saying like
we're spoiled but uh even when you leave
new york i'd be like damn yeah yeah just
trying to major shopping there you don't
see no advertising nothing you see
playstation everywhere no that's a good
point that's a good point as soon as you
see a blue billboard you don't even know
what it is but you automatically assume
yeah that's the playstation that yes
that's what they what is you know it's
like
they are the main headline sponsors for
both the england football team and this
and the french football team but it does
nothing like it means absolutely nothing
like xbox is
for england football team and partner
sponsor for france for federation of
football
but it doesn't do anything like the
reason advertisement is just a press
release so you think advertisers in the
wrong
area they need to allocate it
differently where it's going okay like
they've got a lot like they do these
headline things where they're just like
oh we've partnered with such and such
like well that's great but that's not
advertising to anybody
that's real well that's true
is a partner right that doesn't tell you
anything about the service
or the games that you get in the service
or anything like that there's no like
ads on tv like for game pass we'll just
do an ad for one game and then say play
it in game pass
the game pass ad needs to highlight all
of the big franchises
not just one game
because if you're sure every like like a
glimpse of even 10 15 games in this like
little one and a half minute ad
you're going to get a lot more people
interested go what that's only like 10
pound a month yeah it's cheaper than
netflix right now and like with the cost
of fueling everything going through the
roof and
like i i want to get the newest games
but i can't afford to right now because
like
literally gas and electric has doubled
if not
now when people like all these
all these people talk about watching the
money or or you can't afford it because
you're broke like real real time like
worldwide right now we are in a
situation where the cost of living is
absolutely huge
family
it's getting like it's getting tight
yeah so services like this that allow
people to continue to get the newest
thing on the market
without breaking the bank
is most definitely something that should
be shouting about from the rooftop
because it is needed right now yeah
without it without it people are
literally going to be getting like
scraping together money for for like a
couple of weeks just to get one game
it's going to be like the old days again
well they're doing that now on the
playstation side 70 bucks
microsoft could do so it's equivalent of
90 bucks over here yeah i know i could
solve it canada is a hundred and
something very simple right
you you invested in gay you gave
gamestop some money you moved everybody
to the back of the store okay you did
that right how about do the small ads
on these damn apps that everybody got on
their phone yeah there's a lot they
could improve on for sure right like you
know and then you could you could put
out you could have a commercial in a
tweet
you're talking about them improving on
what they're doing and they have
improved doing everything i mean they
got it
okay
i think okay let's let's let's stop
because y'all there's a lot of captain
nah
i gotta get the you gotta get the haichi
face
and i gotta say not for dutch though
cause dutch is over there so dutch could
tell you more or less he's in the
streets over here
i'm gonna tell you what's going on over
here
all right i see the bethesda commercials
and we already know
is in a shout out to greeny he's working
closely with those bethesda dudes i see
a lot of commercials i see a lot of in
sync type of commercials i see a lot of
smooth r b xbox commercials
but they got here but you know what
they're doing stuff different but listen
what they doing say they must be doing
something right they winning mpds
xbox game passes selling is ringing
bells yeah everybody that's inside every
developer that's inside game passes talk
about how beautiful it is they talk
about it's devastating to their
[Laughter]
we wallet a situation where they are
doing everything right they didn't lose
power they didn't lose price they
they coming in the mpd the games is
ringing off no we're going to keep this
boot on their neck and you don't even
worry about advertising in a minute we
don't want to worry about a minute
about that okay you know why
because all the dudes run into the store
for a playstation keep advertising keep
advertising because they run in the
store and you know playstation's there
you get an xbox so you giving us the
free promo so they doing the work okay
right okay you know what because the
dude the little kid look said mommy i
want that playstation five all right
we're gonna go right to the store they
go right to the store who's in the store
looking at them bull garden little man
right
[Laughter]
this is that conversation you know how
paris do it every like but you speak to
the parent will speak to the sales rep
but don't just play call of duty like
like you want don't it do everything and
it's only 300 the other one is fine
right you know how parents are trying to
rationalize you out of what you
initially want i mean
you don't make you change your whole
life
so i think microsoft looked over at
playstation was like no no no no no let
them keep advertising ain't got no
systems in the store anyway we do so
when you go inside the store and the
fact that they in the front of the store
gamestop and these dudes is in the back
and they're not even there
who you see first little man is out for
the wins
so king what do you feel being that you
mentioned gamestop
the relationship microsoft has a
gamestop the relationship microsoft has
with amd do you feel i love that
i love all that
you know why i love it you know why i
love it you know i listen bro you guys
i'm sick and tired of those dudes and
gay stuff where you going there they be
like well the playstation version is
basically over here
right now the resolution in the
playstation is a little bit higher you
can't say that no more homie you can't
stand them i remember those days that's
right pull up your tablet and get the
xbox out for them and cut it out right
now
i love the fact that you in pocket right
oh my goodness
i love it
i don't know if you have to step away i
had to get your thoughts for you before
you move on
look look look how the narratives
changed right
first was resolution mm-hmm we did that
mm-hmm right
now
metacritic yo my god you see the
supposed meta critic um
[Music]
um
listen listen this is why you don't cap
for things
don't cap for a game
and then when they go on the other
platform we don't hear about you no more
you don't have nothing to say you have
nothing relevant oh yo timeout tell me
oh god i knew what's up guys
guess what i've been playing this week
i've been playing god for the real
edition
and check it out check it out check it
out check it out the field dominus
maximus and really spencer guess how
much i paid for it zero dollars and zero
steps you know why because i got it with
my game rewards you dudes that pay 70
dollars and it was broken it is over
here and it's fixed and it's free shout
out to me for doing that thing and guess
who else i'm playing this week post bug
snap you get bucks next dude okay let's
go who's next get your boxes up baby
boxes this guy devolved into something
else
dirt
bug snacks
my friend
you gonna take me off your friend list
because the second i can download it
it's happening
i didn't we didn't get addicts bars man
i didn't know about all this stuff
that's funny man with this man the mpd
and all this stuff man i mean mpd
tomorrow the european sales excuse me
the european cells
it's just
i think it's good for microsoft because
they have they've never been like very
active over there
and you know
better sells look we know that xbox is
always going to do good in america but
when you start selling better in other
places
that's when you know that they're
starting to pick up more of a world of
pill
the fact that they're doing so much
better than europe and the fact that
they're outsell even it like the limit
playstation fives that's there should
still be better
than the xbox that is stalked there
considering how bad they lost last
generation the fact that microsoft is
even winning regardless of limitations
and anything means that they are picking
up more steam there than they've had for
the longest time i think it's good
because at the end of the day the most
important thing is the like the
longevity and how much they could sell
in general throughout the years and i
take a microsoft right now
that has no console games really let's
keep that in mind they don't even have
games right now that right now like sure
they have stuff coming out but they
don't have anything like of relevance
why not
is absolutely right and if anybody want
to sit here and say
that
i know some guys try to run with it
that this is the same as the xbox one
this they're the same as they was in the
xbox one generation
you need to do me a favor
go in your bathroom because i know it's
dirty oh get some with that clean your
bathroom mirror wow look at yourself in
the smackins oh but because nobody can
sit here
and tell me the xbox for this generation
the xbox series generation
is going the same as the xbox one
generation
you're talking so much smack i'm gonna
go check my bathroom real quick
listen man y'all yeah crazy messy today
but
listen
listen get your ball i figured you had
to get it out your system right listen i
get it i get it i don't the reason why i
don't go crazy because i do understand
what you guys are saying especially king
from last generation right and and
especially with dutchess beat down right
and corrected mistakes
that's a fact right so yeah i'm for it i
i thought that um you know they made
some great strategic moves i i like to
see the european thing the european
thing is huge because to be honest
that's in my opinion jim ryan's
rise
he's from my neck of the woods oh really
from the north of england from norfolk
so it's like people don't realize like
that to me is a very underrated reason
to why the generation last generation
went the way well they got dominated and
they got dominated right to see them
fight there and i know people say well
it's a stop
it doesn't really matter as long as
people are getting the consoles
yeah they're buying them and they're
buying it what is that that's a good
point that's a good point i mean jim got
them hard bottoms and phil got on them
rubber bottoms and ain't a fight
jimmy's slipping all around the places
feeling slipping and dipping them
wearing crocs
bro let's let's be honest here
the united states is xbox territory but
europe is playstation territory yes yes
yes period yes
yes something a conversation is being
held that y'all
are losing or they're even neck and neck
with you yep that's showing a statement
in itself you don't have to prove
anything we're here now now we're not
playing with you
and people when when more people are
buying word of mouth is going to kill
you game pass is the truth and attic
made a fantastic point i think that
people don't realize the thing that's
impressive about it whether you want to
say shortages or not
let's be real outside of the big back
large fries of the shake which we know
we're going to do what they do halo
you know what i'm saying gears we know
that's going to do what they do
these first party choice ain't even like
star field starts up right at the end
next you know hopefully next year
whether it be the hellblades the avows
all the but there's the titles hopefully
next year the call of duty launches and
the activision deal goes through then it
becomes this deluge
of xbox first party studios that are
launching day and date in this service
that's growing and then consoles growing
in regions that they were not dominating
and the word of mouth continues to
spread and that again it's early i'm not
popping off what happens then though
right that's how you start
to win a generation
if
if you get listen xbox has been
fortunate too we ain't gonna say they
ate you know pandemic did help them on
some levels oh yeah
we're not gonna act
like sometimes by themselves i'm just
saying they got the foresight it was two
people in the pandemic and one person
and one person didn't
[Laughter]
it definitely helped out playstation
but microsoft had that cut in line money
during the pandemic right
one person while it was bigger
whether the storm cash and these dudes
i gotta chill right here
jim ryan made the worst move ever he
said yeah we're going to cut back on the
playstations because right now the chips
are too high
chips hi please
i got that in my couch cushions hey hey
uh
wow hey listen listen do me a favor uh
give me a couple of hundred mil so we
can put in our uh their servers you know
to help playstation out when they get
their stuff on
here let's get it
but look i mean
you gotta really be real right
microsoft got more money than them yeah
and they was tired of these deals being
cut yeah you know what i'm saying and
it's big bank take little bank you want
to start you want to play with money
bethesda
oh we oh we we have final fantasy vii oh
yeah activision blizzard now what
all right no i feel what you say listen
we bought house mark
what's the other game
that's what i'm talking about that's the
one that was out there in 86 she was out
there with bobby schmurder in them
you were digging look i will say
i will do this to king's point i will
say there is you have to give credit to
foresight right foresight regardless
look they they they're getting off this
generation you know say i feel
what a what the most positive potential
start considering
all the first party games ahead
considering the fiasco a little bit with
halo infinite and the fact that they are
you know winning mpd's they're in the
mix they're doing things and i would say
it's integrated all that's gonna change
when that miles morality the new
spider-man hit though
when they're all hit
okay so right now y'all hear me capping
right yeah yeah you see the hayachi face
right
sooner spider-man
yeah that's what my playstation 5 go
keep going and then we know when their
bangers do hit so it's gonna be look
it's gonna be a competitive generation
that's pretty much all i got let's get
these super chats and get up all out of
here i'm gonna say one thing just out of
the game last thing i think people can't
underestimate is the
the family games
specifically with with little man like
you've got to think with the amount of
families and things that are buying
little man for christmas and things like
that even for the younger generation and
you're getting all these little family
games in there whether or not it's lego
games or roblox or anything in between
huge like that type of stuff because
they're like there's so much for them to
choose
and so like
and so many different experiences like
kids are literally spoiled for choice
there's so much on there as well that
families can be happy to vote yeah they
could be gonna save their unfortunate
kids are gonna be absolutely over the
moon fantastic
the five people potentially right the
rumors are on the plan then you think
about
them removing the free-to-play barrier
in time right for the games like the
fortnites and all these games that are
free to play that not requiring the xbox
live gold thing you know the potential
of xbox live gold being merged we're
hearing into a tier as well like they're
setting themselves up if they do this
like this is a fantastic start you gotta
for the generation we have to give it to
them and yeah it's it's a fight it's
gonna be a fight it's not they're not
they're not playing no games like what a
way said you know it's like okay you
want to lock out time exclusives you
want to play you know these games and
stuff like that and business-wise as far
as how people move as far as locking
things out they're buying the building
and you got to use your biggest if your
asset is your war chest you got to use
it and they finally have from up top to
use it hey you guys i gotta go my back
is hurting now do you do that that's it
show the chair before you leave show
people what you were suffering with i
gotta show that [ __ ]
his butt went numb
oh
your stomach go to sleep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey stop that
[Laughter]
you laid out how you choose to lay down
[Laughter]
moving along shout out to uh free suge
knight
with the five hour super chat
i'll be eligible for parole in 2037. the
same year sony will have a multiplayer
game worth playing shout out to the
olive oil wow
they are just out of pocket 20 37 good
god yeah they're out of pocket right now
let me get the rusty super chats because
it is crazy that was my man
all right so we got we did smelly rest
the geek all right oh damn here we go
okay so for havoc with the five dollar
super chat shout out to super bot
christopher hart see you here again next
week okay
leroy huston two dollars of jack king is
messy yes he is
drunken ninja five hour super chat iop
doing the lord's work on the lord's day
blessed to be here and part of this
community so what do you drink a ninja
salute
smelly wrestling geek he's back ten
dollars in the chat sony needs to worry
about buying up exclusive games and cop
that chip priority wow yeah no no he put
that twice in the chat he's oh he says
sony needs to not worry about buying up
exclusive games and cop that [ __ ]
priority so he corrected himself with
the secondary super chat spartan goes 17
with the two pound phil needs to put
them ads on stage coach buses bruh
uh dutch do we approve state goals
watches
okay cool stage coaches like the
national bus like yeah local bus
services
that's like your greenhouse
and he said that and i was just like no
yeah i ain't know what it was like red
dead redemption cut that out
[Laughter]
moving along good thing we had dutch for
the clarification mr mr irishman
mr irish mr lew five pound super chap
xbox paying for chip priority from amd
has the same energy as playstation
playing for game priority from square
yeah okay
do it right you go jonas the dad two
dollar super chat s on s on the kids
room x in the living room can't get one
ps5 all right
tj oros being messy like forte two live
super chat hey bestie
salute to dj that's my destiny brethren
that's the homie salute being messy for
havoc we'll just fight out of super chat
isn't that the worst narrative for
playstation if little bro is out here
selling the ps5 okay
spartan go 17 two pounds super chat and
sorry death stranding plot was utter
rubbish okay
no more oscar 2000 i'm getting fed up
from game pass and easter plates
oh you're getting fed oh eating okay i
got you i got you okay okay i thought
you been fed up you're getting fed from
game pass and easter play so you eat two
times okay that's what you do spark goes
seventeen
two five super chat if game pass gets
fifa day one they'll get europe on lock
dodge do we agree
yes okay he agrees
skill no excuse matthew asked you he
says it is recently 100
yeah yeah fight out of some chat i tell
you the biggest flex is mlb the showing
game pass but full price on playstation
it's crazy to think about
agree scrub nerves five hours of chat
100 plus games is bad marketing as well
496 game pass games through xcloud pc
and console they need to get better
verbage and hype but xbox is still
selling no doubt it's true bro that's
true no doubt
cheney salute i remember two loss of
jack king i think xbox does need to
expand market share in other regions by
marketing more effectively xbox has
little to no market share in most of the
world the marketing game needs to be
stepped up king
yeah they do but what they want to do is
put the stuff inside the store so when
they do market people can go and know
what they're going to get see it's not
like playstation marketing and nobody
because they don't have nothing in the
store it will be like somebody gonna
wait for you nobody's waiting for you
little man in the store keep on
marketing little man gonna get sold
keep on doing what you're doing sony i
love it
see you next month
matt him and
quick question for the lord oh
after a few episodes of halo being
released
how do you feel about the show i am
enjoying the show very much regardless
of the helmet trauma let's get around
quickly yes no halo show love it love it
okay one way
off too okay okay yeah i love it i don't
got addict to defend me so i will
refrain but
i said i will not fight here yeah yeah
yeah all right guys
i'm leaving this hello shout out to
master cheeks
apollo cooper
[Music]
xbox was talking mad ish when they
showed off the bethesda acquisition
commercial that was just so fire just
wait until activation arrives he ready
he's ready okay
i think we got all the joints
there was a um
help me out brother help me out if i
missed uh there is a remember be lou
member for eight months
lords salute to y'all keep killing it
and king great great hanging out with
you on stream for the fights last night
thank you brother um
as you saw me uh reading and and going
in the chat you know y'all didn't have
to super chat y'all was just hanging out
with he was having a good time and i did
appreciate everybody that showed up yo
they put in wooden chairs in the chat
for addiction
sleep on his they said addicts sleep on
his stomach with the door open
[Laughter]
you cannot do my man like that that is
[Laughter]
and they got wooden chairs in the chat
they are wild smart go 17 500
we gonna need one will smith for every
playstation longbox carrying nuts and
bolts for playstation plus y'all got
robbed okay
and that's it all right
that was funny that y'all killed me yo
salute oh one more last one hard key
should be finalized which are the laws
planning to do anything with the
community that packs yes pull up pull
ups we will be at pax he's gonna give
you that information in a minute so if
you're in boston pull up the laws 108
dragons gonna be in the building we got
the ghouls on deck don't you talk crazy
you better be respectful okay let me
stop
wait we coming we coming with peace we
coming with peace and engagement i don't
know about all that i come with the same
energy you come when you come with the
wrong energy
you go definitely
exactly what's going on no violence
[Laughter]
anyway salute to the realm for holding
us down let's get this poll question to
get out of the fight get out of here new
iop log net poll with the latest rulers
of project tatanka being halo infinite
version of battle royale how important
do you think this mode is for halo
infinite's long-term success the choices
are a halo infinite need to deliver on
pc fixes co-op forge and lack of content
to improve their player count as first
priority
b
halo infinite battle royal could be a
huge boon to the player base as a
popular game mode and gain a new
generation of halo fans who are not fans
of arena shooters only
or c i don't care it's a huge missed
opportunity if skins from master cheeks
tv series aren't included shout out to
all the people in the chat that's going
to rock the vote it is up on iop lost
gaming.net salute to the legendary 108
dragon tv salute to the legendary dirk
griggity taking time on the easter
sunday salute to the legendary wondering
dutch from the midweek mix up always
holding me down if i need it appreciate
you guys man this is love i know it's
east i know everybody should be with
their families and some people partying
the night before went away but
listen fight parties in new york is the
best listen yeah
i i appreciate y'all man really you have
no idea y'all made this show so much
more fun everybody salute to solve
everybody so let's do our outros let's
get let's get one away first cause we
gonna see him soon in a couple days and
christmas came early suckers let's go
nice
this is nice
that drip
[Music]
[Music]
yeah he ready ready let's go thanks for
having me
it was a pleasure it's always a pleasure
um shout out to everybody that showed up
in the chat y'all dudes dirt wandering
dutch king my brother
uh cog dude is always schooling me with
something and uh shout out to my man
cheeks
[Laughter]
i love adam i love today's the best day
yeah he was elected
tv channel man i appreciate y'all that's
where i'm at man we're gonna be blind
from packs no doubt
cameras off the same cheeks
[Laughter]
we gotta get that make sure y'all
subscribe to the channel you know what
i'm saying put that chat we gotta put
that channel link up in there right
quick you know what's crazy mm-hmm
what's up i didn't even know they had
chairs for the chat what did they find i
didn't even know about that
they lose
real quick just doing me a favor y'all
hit my brother up 108 dragon tv links in
the chat right now
go subscribe to the channel dragon's den
when's dragon's den man what's that
podcast you do man every saturday baby 6
pm eastern standard time we just we give
you that good game of knowledge man no
bias over there just telling you what
telling you what you you you need to
know i like that you already know i like
that
that's how we do it you know i like that
salute man you already seen though
keeping it official keeping it official
you know what i'm saying no no i don't
want to be messy on dirt channels
[Laughter]
on my channel
[Laughter]
you got a salute legendary dirt griggity
tts all that you know what i'm saying so
look man where can the brothers find you
again thank you for holding us down talk
to the people man let me tell you guys
something i had a ball on the show man
uh man you listen you guys are hilarious
man
chad was having a good time oh they was
enjoying myself man i enjoyed myself
y'all added cheeks man
disrespectful
shout out to nine lives
that was wild this is wild crazy that's
funny man shout out to nine lives i'll
be seeing them in my chat too no guys i
appreciate the invite man
uh it was a it was a lot of fun
uh check out my uh channel
you know i actually you know it's funny
i actually did a
little solo like hour podcast by myself
this morning i wanted to do it after my
boy newt newcomb but before you guys
yeah so i was able to do that and then
no added hit me about my of course man
you know i'm not doing anything um so
thank you guys um
you know my podcast wbg xbox podcasts
subscribe to the channel let's go
i want to tell you
we're messy
we're messy over there
you give it a disclaimer okay i like
that like just
please understand it's a different
energy over there
it's a different energy unlike my boy
runaway we are biased uh we're not
definitely ready to r and we know we
have a lot of fun over there and uh also
shout out my boy uh sean 786 podcast
made him do a podcast on fridays on his
channel called tts xbox podcast so we
just have a lot of fun man but thank you
guys for the invite oh man i had a great
time no doubt you already know salute
and of course we'll be remiss if we did
not mention the homie my european
brother wondering dutch of the midweek
mix-up podcast tell the fine people
where they can find you again thank you
for holding us down brother it's fun to
have you and get some perspective
yeah no problem always always a pleasure
to be here and obviously when you if you
ever use a short um uh i'll be free to
jump in appreciate you um
but uh yeah you can find me in about one
hour actually
um with a special neck oh
xbox error
okay uh what y'all doing and then on
wednesday again we've got incepted ghost
from xbox
okay
and of course on the weekend coming
after that we have the indie showcase
that's right in the showcase 2022 uh
with yourself yes of course yes we've
got pong and steel kia sandy we've got
the thistle dude gaming boxing
and then of course special guests aaron
greenberg oh
let's get it when it's dropping when
it's oh great oh greedy's going to all
this is fine listen man
salute the wonder and dutch i'm putting
his information you know subscribe to
the wandering dutch channel again
youtube's in there make sure y'all hit
that up and salute to you because one
thing i really respect what you guys do
keeping indie games alive really
promoting the culture you know these
these smaller games that don't get
enough time and you know whenever i do
have time to try to help you i'll do a
little drop for y'all i've caught a
little you know what i'm saying i try to
help out because this is important and
you guys are getting spotlight to the
right things i loved seeing the growth
over there shout out to the whole team
shout out your team out man you know
the team about the whole yeah yeah we've
we've got a such a stretching team now
because obviously
dude right there by the way
you know he got he got silk lovers
he got that show below he got silk
leather
his aura
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
her dog he's always a funny character
yes then we've got of course like i
mentioned we've got the the massive
collective so we've got several podcasts
uh underneath our wings at the moment as
well
yeah including 11 split screens of pong
and steel
gamers watch podcast nice
nice including talk story from hawaii
talk story yes mango with them i forget
it was hawaiian brothers yes
awesome awesome
of
guys
general see
101 decision we'll probably be adding a
few more later on this year but uh yes
six or seven different creators as well
european bad boy records
[Laughter]
you decided to make podcasts
now i salute to you brother man it's
cool to see what's going on man i love
it again it's all about gaming all about
the passion shines through and again
appreciate y'all man it was love a lot
of fun today let's get a couple of
chances we do got to run uh i mean i'm
not touch um anybody can help me out if
i missed anything i got uh her geek i
think i got apollo cooper two dollar
swim chat kratos loves the kids okay
yeah you'll see and then i think let's
see tai
uh casares oh yes
you missed the super chat i hope i got
it hopefully i got that joy um
halo tv show again be selling that
positive crack okay oh
wow i see what you just did there i
caught that i see what you just did
there i think we are good look everybody
unless anybody got anything else enjoy
your sunday happy easter y'all again for
rocky whatever
yeah over 600 guys in there all right
just for the record so we know we played
a business
the lords will not be here next sunday
i'm saying the laws will be traveling to
pax we'll be there giving you guys
exclusive coverage interviews we got
some fire games lined up you have no
idea also check out 108 dragons channel
as well he's going to be there he's
going to be doing a lot of content you
know i'm saying media is in the building
and this is what we do you know i mean
so we're going to try to get you guys a
lot of exclusive coverage eyes locked on
yes gaming.net
keep your eyes locked on it the youtube
channel is going to be popping on
the gaming.net ring off yeah we got
things cooking and it's exciting to be
at the convention once again and we're
starting to see some things so check go
check it out yo
see me in public
streets
relax relax kill him
i was going to say king yeah y'all out
in boston and y'all at pax pull up and
say hello pull up and say no no
definitely do that
twitter ain't outside don't be coming at
me
we coming for the positive view
you sit there with this
[Music]
but now look it's going to be late you
know again check out for the channel
again
it is we're super excited super pumped
there's going to be a lot of content
coming and then what we're going to try
to do last thing i want to say is that
saturday if we're able to we may give
you guys a pre-recorded or a live show
on a saturday so we'll see how it works
our schedule wise to give y'all
something for obviously not going to be
there
because we're traveling back on sunday
y'all so that's what it is so look
everybody happy easter enjoy your day
that's all i got we are out of here
please
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so